Optimal, minimal. At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
I get asked all the time, if you could
only use one supplement, what would it be?
And my answer is
inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day. If you want to give
athletic Greens to try,
they're offering a free 20 count
travel pack for first time users.
I always travel with at
least three or four of these.
This represents a $100 value,
so if you by Athletic Greens,
you get an extra $100 in free product,
so check it up.
Athletic greens.com
forward slash Tim again,
that's athletic greens.com forward slash
Tim for your free travel pack with any
purchase.
This episode is brought
to you by freshbooks.
Freshbooks has become the goto cloud
accounting software for literally millions
of small business owners
who found a faster,
more efficient and much less stressful
way to deal with their numbers and
ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at.
It is used by many of the fastest growing
startups I've invested in or advise
and it's equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis. It is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices, get paid,
track your time and track your clients
if you're self employed and managing
business sometimes means
wrestling with spreadsheets,
crumbled receipts and other scattered
pieces. Freshbooks can really help.
Freshbooks allows you to do many,
many different things very easily.
Preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice. It takes about 30 seconds.
You can set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients and about
two clicks,
which on average we'll get you paid
twice as fast they're new proposals.
Feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline is part of your
estimate. There are many, many
other things. Tracking your time,
the quick proposals that I mentioned,
formatting free, super easy,
late payment reminders so you don't have
to chase people. Automatic expenses,
sharing files and messages with your
client's award winning customer service.
They are extremely responsive.
The interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve,
so in short it's easy.
It saves you time.
And right now freshbooks is offering
an unrestricted 30 day free trial.
For all of my listeners to claim yours,
check it out.
Go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim
and enter Tim Ferris in the how did you
hear about us section and that is funky.
Spell t I m F E R R. I s. S.
So again going to freshbooks.com forward
slash Tim and enter Tim Ferris in
the how did you hear about us section?
Check it out.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
Or is my job to deconstruct
world class performers,
people who are the best at what they
do to tease out the habits, routines,
life lessons,
favorite books,
favorite cooking pans and so on that
you can use in that last little bit with
some heavy foreshadowing for this episode.
My guest today is Samine knows rot.
You can find her at Chow Samine,
C I a o at Chelsea and
on Instagram and Twitter.
Facebook forward slash just I mean dot
knows route and the website is salt fat
acid,
heat.com which we'll be getting
into and Simien is amazing.
She is a writer, a chef and a teacher
in my mind, first and foremost,
absolutely masterful teacher and excellent
at turning complexity into simplicity.
Her in New York Times
bestselling at first book, salt,
fat acid heat or if the James Beard
award that's like at the Oscar's best
picture for best general cookbook and
was named cookbook of the year by the
International Association
of Culinary professionals.
But this episode is about so
much more than just cooking.
It is about the creative process. It
is about creative, highest creative,
low is pushing through rejection, you
name it, it's very, very vulnerable.
If you liked the Brandon Stanton episode,
you are going to love this episode
and it covers some heavy stuff,
some really important stuff.
But back to the bio a,
Simeon has been called quote the next
Julia Child and quote by Nprs all things
considered and she has been cooking
professionally since 2000 when she first
stumbled into the kitchen at blank,
blank blank.
We're going to cover what that blank
blank blank is like Hanukkah restaurant
that no doubt you've heard of and a what?
An amazing genesis story.
It is an eat columnist for the New York
Times magazine, so I mean lives, cooks,
reads and gardens in Berkeley,
California.
Her latest project is absolutely gorgeous.
It is a Netflix original documentary
series that may sound familiar.
Salt,
fat acid heat,
same title as the book produced by
a jigsaw productions. And I heavily,
heavily recommend that you check it
out. It is absolutely gorgeous. Salt,
fat, acid, heat on Netflix. So without
further ado, please enjoy this.
Very wide ranging and very vulnerable.
And to my mind,
very important conversation
with Simien no syrup.
Simon, welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me, Tim and I,
I know that people are gonna say,
wait a second,
he just mispronounced her name and I want
them to know that I double and triple
check that with you beforehand.
A lot of people say some mean because
that would be English friendly,
but the correct pronunciation of
your full name is what I mean. Yeah.
You have like a graduated
past the American
pronunciation into, you're going for
two Persian right now. So it's good.
I will get there,
I will get there
and I struggled with deciding
where to begin topically,
this conversation.
But one thing really jumped out at me
and I wanted to begin there since I like
to follow my interest and that
is the manifestation journal.
Can you tell me about your
manifestation journal?
I'm so happy you're asking. Um, um,
so I don't know where the idea for
my manifestation journal came from.
I think it may have been like a self
help blog in approximately 2008, but,
um, it's just a notebook that I
bought him, like art supply store,
it's just a sketch book.
And I just decided to start writing
down the things that I envisioned for my
life and whether they were really big
and I would ever be like too embarrassed
to articulate them to anyone or
whether they were really little.
And I tried, I sort of knew initially
that I should be as specific as possible.
And what's pretty bananas is
sometimes I'll misplace the journal,
like it'll slide under my bed and I'll
forget about it for, I don't know,
six months or something.
And then I'll pull it out.
I think at one point I lost it for about
two years and I'll pull it out and I'll
look and I'll be like, oh
my gosh, like word for word.
So many of these things have
happened, you know, and I think, um,
and there were also many things in there
that have not come true yet or like
maybe I was misguided and I changed and,
and goals shifted.
But it is really sort of mind blowing to
go back and look at how specific goals
sort of come to life.
When you plant a seed,
you know the or you achieve things when
you plant a seed and you're really clear
about it. And I've always known that
and I've always really adhere to that.
And so it's just one little
practice that I have at this point.
I like to look at it around my
birthday and around the new year.
Those are sort of the two times of year
that I have pretty diligently we'll
check in and right into
it. But it's not, you know,
it's not a big thing that I do all
the time, but it is really incredible,
especially as I've started to sort
of achieve bigger goals in my career.
To go back and look at it and say,
wow,
like I wanted always to write for
this publication and now I am,
or I really specifically wanted,
you know,
a book deal with a certain amount of
money and I achieved it. And you know,
and it's,
yeah.
Well I've, I've so many followup
questions because I'm a nerd.
When it comes to journaling and notebooks
and it's something that the comes up a
fair amount in this podcast from profile
in the California Sunday magazine.
Uh, this was discussed in
a few lines and when the,
the interviewer in this case flipped
through the notebook, which uh,
I'm jealous of immediately, Eh, it,
it
give a few examples.
Next in quote next to small candid
instructions to herself. Example,
Chin hairs under control,
exclamation point in general life notions
in parentheses, Bay Leaf Pin, Yada,
exclamation point.
I'm not sure what that is but that's okay.
We'll come back to it. There were goals
that I found striking in their precision.
Go to Italy, write and publish
at least one story in print,
start writing her first book. Those
were dated 2008 and all have come true.
So my question is when you were,
do you still use the journal?
If, so, generally speaking,
say from 2008 forward,
how frequently do you write in the journal
and then what does the review process
look like?
Um,
I do still use it.
I probably write in it
two or three times a year.
And I also probably look at
it two or three times a year.
Um, and it's a treat to look at it now
it's become this amazing treat where,
where I get to,
um,
go back and see did something happen,
you know,
did I achieve something or
did some thought or notion
that I had had at sometime
come true. Um, and it really is,
and often it's a nice thing to sort
of help me refocus where I'm headed.
I feel like with my career.
Um,
in a lot of ways it's how to really, uh,
what's the word I was going to say? Like,
Oh,
a more fifth shape.
There has not been one super clear goal
or one super clear path that I can model
my career on. There aren't a lot of
other writers, chef, teacher, you know,
often people are just write about
food or just cook or just teach.
And so I have done all those things and
more and I've always just followed my
gut. And that can be really
overwhelming because, um,
I get really distracted quite
easily by shiny objects, you know,
or like a lot of money or the opportunity
to work with somebody or make a
decision because of I'm worried what
will happen if I say no. And um,
so I feel like the clearer I
am about what I do want to do,
the more easily I can say no or,
or just make a better decisions
about where I'm headed.
So even just a couple times a year having
like a little bit of quiet time and it
usually I'll pick up the thing a couple
of days before my birthday and start
thinking about like what I've done in
the past year where, what, uh, where,
you know, good choices, I've made
bad choices I've made. And um,
yeah, I, and it sort of as a nice sort
of personal check in, I don't know,
there's a million names for these things.
I don't know why I wrote manifestation
journal, but it really is that like,
you know, it's also just like
a journal. I don't, yeah.
And when you look at,
when you look at a page,
is it date and then under that just a
series of bullets for things that you hope
to achieve?
Yeah,
I mean if I were a little more organized
and there would probably be like some
sort of method of the
math, but it's, you know,
it started out as bullets and the
other day I was telling somebody,
I was reading some of the ones from the
very first page for someone and then I
always saying how, oh, there's
all these things like I dunno, um,
published four books,
you know,
popular well-reviewed books that I'm proud
of by goodwill, non publishing houses.
And then in at the very bottom in
tiny, tiny writing, like so small,
I could barely admit it to myself.
And I certainly can't believe
I'm about to tell you,
but I wrote in the tiniest writing,
MacArthur genius grant. Like, like,
it's so embarrassing. Do
you know what I mean? Like,
so like I can't believe it's just so
embarrassing. And then, yeah, I wrote,
I had a page for long term goals.
I had a page for what I
hoped to do that year ideas.
There's the bailiff Kenyatta, which
was I wanted to make a penny, Yada.
That was covered instead of
with crepe paper with Bailey of,
so when you hit it with a baseball bat,
it smells really good and we did it.
We did it on my 30th birthday.
If you're looking at this journal
to picking it up three times a year,
let's say two or three times a year,
is the significance that you are
planting a seed in your subconscious more
smooth because it sounds like you're not
going back and sort of reviewing it and
some type of spreadsheet fashion.
Looking at the progress towards the
end goal in each of these cases,
you're visiting it two or
three times a year. Is,
is the importance then that you're
planting a seed in your subconscious that
will somehow very subtly
direct your choices in a
different fashion? I know that,
that, uh, a number of people who've been
on this podcast, my friend Josh Waitzkin,
who is the basis for searching
for Bobby Fischer, Reid Hoffman,
do quite a bit of a intention setting
or journaling either right before bed or
first thing upon waking up,
which has that flavor to it.
But why do you think this has had an
impact in your life if it has had an
impact?
I definitely think this lines up with
idea of planting a seed in my subconscious
and also helping me like
remain accountable to myself.
And then I also have all manner of
other intention setting and goal making
unless making just at my office, above
my desk, I have lists of, you know,
actually it's funny,
I had a list of um,
interviews I would like to do
and yours was on the list, right?
And so I looked at that list, they
looked at that list, you know,
every day I went to work
and sat at my computer.
There's a list right next to that of
maybe projects I would like to do. Right.
And then right next to that is a list
of collaborators I would like to have,
you know,
and there's people on there like wildly,
I sort of just stopped being embarrassed
at some point about having sort of what
seemed wildly unachievable dreams or,
or you know,
I put Esra and Ava Duvernay on that list.
Do I know them?
Is there any possibility that, you
know, I don't know, like what do I know?
I just put them on there because there
are people I would like to maybe work
with whose work I respect.
And so, um, there is,
I just had to stop being afraid that
someone would come into my office and see
that and judge me, you know,
like, and so for a while,
when I first started writing the book,
I wrote visualize Oprah's book club.
And I had that on a post it
note above my desk for years.
And then Oprah's book club ended. But, um,
and also I don't think she puts cookbooks
on, but you know, I've never dare,
I wouldn't say I've ever been
embarrassed to, to dream big.
And I think the better I have gotten at,
at articulating my dreams and words and
then I'm really just being mindful of
them and whether it means coming back to
them once or twice a year or looking at
them every day,
I do feel like it makes a difference
and it helps me stay on track.
And then if I look at that list and after
a while some goal or some name or some
idea, it doesn't feel right anymore,
I can cross it off, you know?
I don't know. It's just
um, it's a nice thing,
especially when I'm in the,
you know,
in those sort of rock bottom
part of the creative process.
Like where you're just sort of
doing the draft, the boring stuff.
You're doing the accounting,
you're doing the like terrible
writing that's not coming out easily.
It's just nice to look up and be like,
Oh yes,
I am a creative person who
has big ideas and you know,
sometimes makes things happen.
So I don't know. It's not,
it's like a little bit of
cheerleading for myself, I guess.
This is really important.
So I want to explore it for a moment.
This and this is going to
be very non chronological.
We're going to bounce all over the place.
I do have questions about San Diego,
but we're going to come to that first
since you said the rock bottom of the
creative process,
so when you are in the rock bottom of
the creative process and almost anyone
except for a few mutans here or there
who just seem to always operate in the
proper gear,
but for most people with any large
or unfamiliar creative project,
there's going to be maybe one rock bottom,
maybe many different rock
bottom difficult moments.
Do you use anything we're talking
about in some ways future tense,
the things you want to do when you
were in that rock bottom place,
do you use anything from the past,
things you've achieved or milestones
you've accomplished or anything from the
present tense to also help buoy your
spirits or is it mostly the keeping your
eye on the ball that is ahead of you,
that future tense that helps you?
I think I wish that,
I think I need some more therapy and
meditation to get to be the kind of person
who can feel good about my
past accomplishments and
let them bully me to um,
to buoy me forward.
I think I sort of achieved the
thing and then I forget about it.
Like it's even part hard for
me when I receive praise,
I get so many emails all the time,
which are so meaningful in a way.
These are maybe the most meaningful kind
of feedback that I get is from people
who are like,
I read your book and Now I Cook
Vegetables for my kids and they eat them,
you know, and it tastes good.
And that kind of stuff is really,
I think the most powerful for me. But
still there's a way where I'm like, oh,
somebody else did that I had.
And it's really hard for me to accept
praise or really fully feel in my body
pride and happiness at
having achieved these goals.
I have listed on papers
all over the place. So I,
I do a lot of work in therapy and
meditation and just like, you know,
trying to be better about my body and
connecting with my body and feeling that
stuff. So here, up until now,
I have not historically used those things
to get me through the creative lows.
I often,
um,
once I do have to sort of
keep my eye on the prize,
I think in therapy and
in just my own life,
I have had to do a lot of
work in reframing what success
means and what it looks
like. So that as I work
toward quote unquote success,
um,
I'm working towards something that will
be positive for me rather than then also
beat me down. Like I'm a crazy
perfectionist child of immigrants who,
you know, like was raised in a family
where nothing was ever good enough.
Nothing I did was ever like
perfect, you know, it was just, I,
I'm perfectionist from childhood and
then I entered a profession and in
particular like began working at an
institution which is run by like a
worldclass perfectionist. And so, and so,
nothing that any of us
ever did was good enough,
which is good because it keeps us
pushing all toward doing better.
But I haven't historically had a lot
of like positive feedback and really
allowed myself to feel that.
So I'm doing a lot of my own work to
sort of be proud at the things that I do,
whether they're perfect quote unquote
or just good enough or whatever.
And um,
you know,
I had a lot of fear before my
book was released that, uh,
because it was the biggest
project that I had ever worked on.
It was a la the longest dream
that I had ever worked toward. Uh,
I had put everything I had into it and
because it took me so long to do a lot of
people,
at least I felt the pressure of a lot
of people looking at me and at this book
and people were waiting for it and I knew
they were ready to respond in whatever
way. Right. I didn't know what
way. And I have always, you know,
like worked for external
praise and I'm aware of.
And so I went to therapy and
I told my therapist, I said,
I'm really worried that when this book
comes out that I am going to sort of sink
or swim on the world's reception
of it and I don't want to do that.
So how do I get out of that?
How do I exist in a way where,
um,
whatever the reception is of this thing,
I will still be okay and not like break
into 1 million pieces. And so he said,
well, we have to create a definition
of success that's on your terms.
So it took me a lot of
months and a lot of thinking.
And eventually I came back to
him and I said, you know what,
I'll feel totally successful with this
if I know that I've done everything I
could possibly do to make it
as good as I possibly can.
And that means never,
you know,
being lazy and not doing another revision
or never not doing the research or
never not hiring the fact checker or
never not testing the recipe again or
whatever. And that once I know I've given
everything and like turned every stone,
then I will be able to
respond to any criticism.
I'll be able to accept any praise because
I'll know that I did anything right.
To me,
a big,
big thing about responding to criticism
is if there's a reason I made a choice
and I can speak to that articulately,
then um,
I'm happy to accept criticism because
sometimes it's just a difference of
opinion.
But if I felt pressured to do something
or I know that I didn't do my best or
whatever,
then a lot of times that criticism
like really sort of gets me in the gut.
And um,
and so I really did that work.
And I also sort of committed to not
reading reviews and you sort of,
you know,
and not reading comments and stuff.
And so I've sort of shielded
myself from a lot of stuff,
but I have felt to generally really
safe and strong since the book came out.
And it's nice that there is all
of the sort of praise or whatever,
but I also just feel, um, yeah,
I feel good about what I've done and I
know the ways I could've done it better.
There's always an I get to go do more
work in the world and try and do that
better, you know? And it's okay.
How did your therapist help you or how
did you put systems in place so that that
definition of success would be
at the forefront of your mind?
I don't know,
of course,
because I don't have a telepathy,
but I suspect there had to be some
point where you saw maybe it wasn't a
negative review,
but maybe just a lukewarm response or
perhaps just some idiot on the Internet
with a loud voice yelling
something or other.
And for at least a moment you were
back in your old mindset of looking for
external validation and in this case not
finding it. I it, did that happen at all?
If so happens all the time.
So yes.
How do you take that?
I think very enabling
definition of success and kind
of bring it onto the front
lines with you.
Are there any exercises that you did?
Was it the speaking to the therapist
on a weekly basis? How did, how did,
because this is something I struggle with.
I also be have historically beaten
the hell out of myself for the,
the smallest mistakes and always looked
for the things that can be improved
rather than the things
that were done well.
So this is also just selfishly
something I'd love to
Tim, I want to give you a
hug. It's true. It's true.
It's true. I mean I feel you're
like it's, I don't know why I'm,
we are wired this way, but we are and
it's its own struggle. I absolutely,
you know, I still get those emails. One
really clear example that I can think of.
Oh here. You know what, this is so epic.
So I had to separate fact checkers
checking my book for Science,
um, for the cooking science, just
because I'm not a scientist and I,
I'm sure I got some things wrong and it
turned out I got a bunch of things wrong.
And so luckily we caught
almost all of them.
And in the last minute sort of shuffle
to like input all of their changes.
I accidentally, um, what's the word
when you invert? Aye. Aye. Aye.
I said something positive when sh sorta
you should have used a negative, right.
Inverted the thing.
And it ended up being like on the very
first page of anything science related in
the book page 29 and it was like the
most basic definition of osmosis.
Right? And I accidentally inverted
it and gave the opposite definition,
which really sets me up to look like an
idiot, you know, for the next 400 pages.
And,
and so and so,
and it happened in,
and I didn't realize that this
had happened until the very first,
the day of publication when like
the first Amazon reviews went up.
And someone very kindly mentioned it
in an Amazon review and I lost my mind.
I was like, this is going to, you know,
cause 70,000 books had been printed.
I was like,
70,000 people are going to get the
wrong information and understand us.
Moses wrong because of me. Um,
you know, think I'm stupid.
And um, and I sort of just
was like, everyone, you know,
this is comes true that my greatest fear
that I'm not a brilliant food science
person, you know, which I'm
not as brilliant food science
person, like all of this.
And so really sort of was,
and that was really hard for me
to let go of and be like, well,
I made a mistake. It's a mistake. I
tried my best and everything else.
There's going to be many
more copies of this book.
We're going to fix it for the future.
And,
and so I sort of was able to work through
the idea that I had made a mistake,
you know, and a mistake is totally
different than making a bad choice.
Or I had just forgive myself
for making a mistake. And then,
so maybe a year after that,
um,
I received this really nasty email
from somebody who took the time to,
you know, and he was a
scientist, he's a scientist.
And so he took the time to this really
angry email about this mistake and how if
on page 29 it was basically like he,
he actualized the things that I had been
so afraid of a year before and he made
it, he made it true, right? He
manifested my worst nightmare.
And so he wrote me this
really mean email about how,
how could this have made
it to publication and what,
how lazy was I and my publisher
and don't we do fact checking.
And if this mistake is on page 29,
then he couldn't possibly trust anything
else I have to say and all of this kind
of stuff. And by that time,
like I had been so sort of,
I had forgiven myself for this mistake
so clearly that I was able to write back
to him and say, listen, you know, this
was a mistake. I'm sorry for this mistake.
We've remedied it since
in future printings.
And I really hope that the
next time you make a mistake,
people treat you with more compassion
than you just treated me, you know? Yeah.
And so, and so, and then he wrote back,
he actually wrote back and he was
super sorry, but it was just, you know,
that he took, it was a, it came on like
the official letterhead of his university.
And so,
um,
that was a good practice for me to sort
of understand the cycle of this thing,
you know, and um, you know, of
course I'm going to beat myself up,
but like then what do I do right after
that? And so how do I reframe it?
And like often what I like to do is think
about how I treat somebody else or how
I would talk to a friend of mine who
made a mistake is such a mistake or got
received such criticism and I would
always be way nicer to anyone else.
So I'm trying my hardest to
treat myself like that now too.
But that's easier said than done,
you said, than done. But it's, it's,
I think it gets easier with the,
the addition of examples like that and
people hearing that so that they don't
feel quite as alone a but also be enabled
in a sense because they see that it
can be improved. Uh, and I have to,
I have to share one, one book
story because it's, it's, uh,
it's not entirely dissimilar,
but I don't,
I don't know if I've shared it before it,
I just feel compelled because
I'm over caffeinated, which is,
I remember when my first book,
so the four hour work week,
it's getting printed and I'm going
to get my first real copy and I,
I come home for lunch at
one point and there's this,
there's this thick yellow,
a padded envelope that has been shipped
to my house and owns on the doorstep and
I pick it up and I know it's the
book and what I said to myself,
it did not open it. I said to myself,
I know when I opened this book,
I'm going to find a typo and I
need to prepare for that typo.
So I waited all day until like 7:00
PM like poured a glass of wine,
like sat at my kitchen
table and this book.
And then right in the fucking dedication,
huge type of like first,
like even before we get to
the front matter, I'm like,
you have to be fucking kidding
me. I'm glad I have my wine. But,
and at that point, the same
thing, you're like, okay,
there are however many tens of thousands
of these flooding or a hundred people
are going to open it before they even
get to my first paragraph of pros.
I'd be like,
what?
Okay.
Oh my Gotcha.
Oh Man. I mean it's still gets me, I mean,
I write a column for The Times
magazine where, you know,
it goes through two editors,
at least a fact checker and the copy
editor and still mistakes get through,
you know,
and,
and people really take the time to write
to me about grammatical errors and so,
and so I just,
and it always,
I have a little punch in my gut and then
I'm just like, well, it was a mistake.
You know, I, I haven't had,
I'm getting better at one small
way in which I'm getting better at.
Being Nicer to myself is letting
go of mistakes. And it is,
I do think it's really funny for people
like me in here when we're literally
faced with them on the very first page.
Like it's just a good reminder, you know?
No one's perfect.
Yeah.
No matter what.
Like every single time you have a piece
of writing that is important to you,
there will be some error that I think has,
has like a conscious of its own and just
will's itself through all of the copy
editors to make its way into,
into print. But so it goes,
have you found any particular I've,
and I'm not proud of this,
but I've never gone to
therapy. Uh, I've, I've,
I've actually had a few
sessions here and there,
but really something like three or four
sessions over the course of my life and
it never,
I never took to it.
Have you found any particular type
of therapy to be helpful for you?
Um, I love my therapist. I,
he's the only one I've ever been to.
I met him because he was my friend's
boyfriend's therapist. So, um,
and as,
and being an insane
person who I'm just like,
I'm just really highly anxious and
highly, you know, kind of neurotic.
Um,
I googled his name a whole bunch of times
before I went to go see him and after
I started seeing him to try and figure
it out as much information about them and
the kind of therapy that he
practices as possible. But he's,
he's definitely old school therapists.
There's no information on
the Internet about him.
So I actually don't even really know.
I've asked him so many times and he's
really evasive about the specific kinds of
things cause he incorporates, I
think so many different types of, um,
methods into his work. And even in, we've
been together I think almost almost,
maybe not quite 10 years yet,
but um, he's changed a lot.
I can tell that he's going out and
learning and the things that he focuses on
change a lot so far, very frustratingly
to me for a really long time.
His answer to almost anything.
I would say would be like,
and how do you feel in your body?
And I was like,
I don't want to talk about how I feel my
body. I want you to tell me what to do.
Like, what's this
illusion? And so, and so.
Um, but it's like over many years he has
trained me to really be attuned to my
feelings and my body, which I think
that's a lot of somatic work. And, um,
and I think technically what he does
is CBT, cognitive behavioral therapy.
And so that's sort of
the larger framework.
And then within that we do a lot of
meditation and a lot of lives at this
somatic work. And, um,
I feel like for somebody like me who
is so much in my head and so much about
action,
um,
it is such a nice practice and
such a great gift to myself, um,
to have this place where I go once a week
where I am just led back into my body
and into my feelings and have trained
myself to really be aware of my feelings
and not just my thoughts. Um,
I think for, yeah, I, and,
and so I'm so grateful to
him and to this work for that
this,
this is something that's top of mind for
me because a friend of mine just came
back,
uh,
I want to say about a month ago from a
going co Vipassana meditation retreat.
And I've never gone to
Goink meditation retreat,
but it seemed,
at least in his experience
to focus almost,
if not completely a exclusively
on bodily sensations.
You're not following your thoughts,
you're always returning to focusing
on these different bodily sensations.
And I'd love to hear if you're willing,
because I do think this is very important
for me and potentially for a lot of
people listening how
this somatic awareness,
this reconnecting to the body and the
feelings ends up translating to your life.
Right? So whether it's, whether it's,
could you give an example situation?
Yeah, sure. So, um, well, and this, Tim,
it's so crazy because this is not that
different of a conversation than where we
started with the manifestation
journal to be honest. So, um,
I have always been a really
like gut lead person,
you know, intuitive person. And
especially in my career, like where I'm,
I'm making decisions about,
well,
it doesn't feel right to go work for
this or it doesn't feel right to accept
that job. And so, um,
and anytime I've regretted doing
something or I've gotten myself into some
complicated professional
pickle or a personal pickle,
it's often because I ignored
that gut feeling, that gut voice.
And so what this work teaches me to do
is I'm basically just strengthening the
muscle of that gut feeling. You know?
And sometimes it's not just my gut,
it's sometimes my heart feeling.
Um,
but I'm teaching myself to listen to the,
to like really like quiet everything
else really as much as possible,
quiet my mind and all the
things telling me, well,
you should do this or there was this much
money, or shouldn't you do this thing?
Because then you would get to be on a,
you know,
billboard with so and so or whatever,
you know, all these other reasons.
It sort of gets rid of the reasoning and
it helps me listen to my heart and my
gut. So let me think of an example. Um,
that recently happened. Uh, Ooh,
well here, here's a, here's
something you could disguise
details to protect. No, I'm
just, I'm trying to, no, no,
I am, I mean there are, I'm
just trying, they're like, I
have a friend who recently,
so I have been, I've been
in a lot of emotional pain
for the last several months.
I've been in a really sort of just
like feeling the weight of the world.
I have been,
um,
learning a lot of things about my own
life and things that I feel responsible
for in terms of ways that
I've participated in,
in sort of, I don't know, um,
systems that have put me down,
you know,
as like a immigrant kid with
a funny name and sort of,
I had made decisions to maybe if I just
achieve enough that people won't notice
that I'm different and
then they'll accept me.
There's been a lot of
that in my life of like,
let me infiltrate this elite institution
and make my way to the top and then
there will be no way that anyone
can deny that I belong here.
So that's sort of been looking back at
my life. That's been the pattern of,
of everything that I've done and I,
I'm sort of reckoning with what that's
meant for me and how I want to continue
moving forward. And there, there's
a lot of pain in that for me.
So I've been really down and a lot
of my friends can really tell that.
And to the point where a lot of them
started checking in on me like the other
phone via text,
via email and I didn't know why a lot of
people were checking in on me because I
just have been in such sort of rage
and pain and I have had this boulder of
anger and sadness and hurt in my chest.
And about a month ago I went to go talk
to a friend who reached out to me and
she said, please come talk to me.
Like I want to talk to you about this.
I'm worried about you. I'm worried that
you don't have the kind of supportive,
you know,
deeply,
mutually supportive relationships in
your life that will support you through
this.
And also through all of the stuff that's
coming your way with this show coming
out and all this kind of stuff.
So I went there and I thought she was
going to give me a hug and tell me how
much she loves me
and tell me how great I am and I deserve
all this great friendship or whatever.
And she actually sat me down
and she said, you know, these,
these ways in which you've
been letting down me,
you've been letting down the people
around you and I know that you're in pain
cause you feel really
lonely on separate from us,
but you're actually doing it to yourself.
And um,
and so if you can work
on some of this stuff,
I think it will not only improve your
relationships, but you'll feel better.
And I mean, I was not, it was
a real intense come to Jesus.
We were standing on the side of the,
like on the corner of the street
and San Francisco and cry.
We were both crying for like two
hours. It was really intense. And,
and um, I did not expect
it at all. And, you know,
and she said all this stuff.
And my immediate reaction
was to be really defensive.
And then as soon as I started to form
the defensive sentences and, but this,
but that I realize like,
well,
it doesn't even matter because
her experience of me isn't,
it has nothing to do with my reasons
for why I have not been there for her in
this way or that way.
So I just sort of like deflated.
And I looked at her and I said, well, what
do I do? Like, how do I be better for us,
for you, for me, for our friends. And so
she told me, and she said later, she said,
I can't believe you didn't even have a
single defensive reaction like it was. I,
I was really prepared for that.
And it was really amazing that you did it.
So we had this very intense sort of three
hours together where we unpacked all
of this stuff.
And I asked her what I could do,
she gave me a whole list of basic ways
in which I could be a better friend. And,
um, and ultimately I felt very loved
because I think it's really hard to tell
somebody, you know, those
to have those hard talks.
So I felt really loved and cared for by
the fact that she took the time and the
energy and set the intention of setting
me straight in these things. And,
um,
as I was driving home,
I got back into my car and I had this ice.
I sat and I buckled the safe.
I think when I buckled the safety
belt and it went across my chest,
I realize that this pain that this
boulder of pain that has been in my chest
probably at least since December, you
know, six or seven or eight months, um,
was gone.
And it wasn't that I felt
so great all of a sudden,
but this rock that has been weighing
down every breath was no longer there.
And I, um, it,
it sort of maybe had been broken
up and dispersed into my body.
And I woke up the next
morning and I cried. I mean,
I was still really upset about get
receiving this sort of very difficult
feedback. But I also felt realized
I felt really empowered because she,
you know, so much of my pain has been
about a feeling of powerlessness.
Um,
a feeling that like there are so many
things going on in the world that I have
no power to change or improve.
And this,
she gave me something I could do something
about and not only could I do about
it,
but I could make my life better and my
friends' lives better in the process.
And so,
um,
I think having power and feeling,
feeling, feeling the, you know,
very strong and pure love of my friend
really hoped to dissolve this bad
feeling. And this is not to say
like my depression has lifted.
I suddenly feel so much better, but I
will say there was a market difference,
a market immediate difference. And
everyone who I'm around is like, wow,
you're so much lighter.
And I really do feel a lot lighter.
So I don't know if that was
really clear for you, but um,
uh, it's, I think this is
important territory to explore.
So I appreciate you
being game and we will,
we will probably come
back to some of this,
but I don't want,
I want to make sure that we explore the
entire map of the terrain up and down.
And you mentioned,
you mentioned a love a few times,
so I thought perhaps if
you'd be willing to share,
if you could answer the question,
when did you first fall in love with food?
I mean,
was there any particular moment,
any particular meal where it just really
kind of grabbed you by the collar and,
and it made you become as a involves
or excited about food as you are today?
Oh Wow. I don't know. You know,
I don't know because my mom is such
an incredible cook and it was um,
cooking for us and shopping for us and
spending time on food was the primary way
that my mom really showed us her love.
Um,
I think I've always associated cooking
and eating with that feeling of like
maternal warmth, you know? And it's
what I try to put out into the world.
There was, there is, I don't remember
eating less, but the story is out.
I have so many pictures
of myself as a little kid.
And the stories also for me now as a cook,
there's so many things that I understand
about the lengths that my mom went to
to make this really delicious
and nutritious and culturally
meaningful food for
us every day. And how much work went
into that and how much time and labor.
And so, um, there's a lot of
things that in retrospect,
I have so much appreciation for her
about that I probably just couldn't have
ever imagined. But there's this dish
that she, quote unquote invented
called Salmon Polo and Polo just
means rice. And so, and it was,
I think the food she fed me
when I was teething, you know,
and it was this like Mushy,
right?
It was a long like bus Marty rice with
like really soft pieces of potato and
tomato and chicken. And so it was just all
these like, you know, typical kid foods.
Um,
but really,
really soft so that you could eat him
even if he didn't have teeth. And,
and,
um,
and I would eat that with yogurt and I
loved it so much and I loved that there
was a dish named after me,
you know, like, and um,
and I still sometimes go make
that for myself. Like, so to me,
I think the Salmon Polo is a,
is a great example of that. Um,
and it's funny because
there have been for sure,
some really meaningful
meals that I've had. Um,
and there's the one that sort of led me
to become a cook that was I think really
important in the story and
in the timeline. But, um,
very rarely is,
is a meal for me about the food.
It's almost always about what
happens at the table, you know,
in the conversations and the feelings
and all that kind of stuff. So I think,
yeah, for me, like, yeah,
it's maybe also not the healthiest thing
to associate foods so deeply with love,
but, so you were, uh,
well, let me just ask the question. Where
did you grow up? I grew up in San Diego.
I was born there.
My parents came from Iran in
the mid seventies to San Diego.
And then,
um,
I was born in 79 and I have
lived this really funny,
you know, in retrospect, this
really funny life where I was art,
my high school was two
blocks from the beach.
I grew up going to the beach all the
time. I eaten fish Tacos, you know,
hanging, driving around in cars with
all my, like very American friends.
And then I would come home and my mom
always said, when you come back home,
this is Iran. And so at home we spoke
Farsi or Persian rugs everywhere.
We Ate Persian food,
you know,
she insisted that we like follow the
traditions of the culture and respect our
elders. And so I, I
very much had this, um,
these two worlds that I
was very aware of and,
and still sort of look back and think,
think a lot about and,
and think a lot about
how that's defined me.
And I think it led to me feeling like an
outsider no matter where I was because
I'd never quite belonged. And I, in a way,
I think that feeling of never quite
belonging has come into co is one of my
super powers because I,
it's very easy for me even
as I become more like,
quote unquote popular or successful or
whatever to imagine what it's like to be
on the outside.
And so it really has made inclusivity and
inclusion be a fundamental part of all
of my work.
And so whether I'm writing a recipe
for the New York Times magazine and I
constantly put myself into the shoes of
someone who doesn't live in California,
have access to the world's best produce,
you know,
or what ingredients can anyone
buy at any grocery store?
Or will these instructions make sense to
anyone or am I using language that will
make you feel like you don't
belong here or, or, um,
or whatever.
So to me,
it's this funny thing where these things
that caused me so much sort of pain and
confusion as a kid have ended up being,
um,
really wonderful tools and my work.
I'm so glad you're,
you're talking about not fitting
in being a gift and it's just,
it's so timely and I feel like we should,
we should definitely hug
it out at some point. But
literally just a week ago,
I was reflecting on how many of the
things that I've viewed from my past as
having damage to me or resulting in me
being damaged have actually been gifts
and w and one of them was always feeling
in a sense that I didn't fit in and
being an observer,
right?
Because at least I don't know
what your experience was like,
but I very often ended up standing in a
room and feeling like I wasn't actually
there, but I was like a camera on the
wall observing what was happening.
And what I noticed for instance,
in your writing, and I,
I've read a million cookbooks,
uh,
except I certainly would not consider
myself a real chef as you are,
but have read a lot.
I keep very few in my actual kitchen.
And,
uh,
your book is one of those books because
you are so good at putting on the Lens,
uh, of beginner's mind. And
really putting yourself in the place
of whoever it is you are writing for,
who's intended to receive the teaching
that you are putting down on paper or on
the screen.
So I wanted to dig into that a little bit
because I feel that that reframe is so
powerful and it's easy to forget too.
It's easy to forget to put those
glasses on with that reframe. Okay.
For sure. I have, I definitely
have a response to your question,
but also you said something so beautiful
and so crazy that I feel like I needed
to read you this quote that I just saw
on Instagram. No, I'm ready. I'm ready.
Okay. So I just pulled it up. Um,
it was by Marco Pierre White to I,
do you know who he was? Yeah, that's
what, is it? White heat or white hot.
What was the book that he, was this
like, um, he is, he's not, he's not,
he's still alive. Sorry, sorry.
Marco Pierre White. Um, he,
he, I don't even know how
to describe him. He was a,
a trendsetting avant garde chef in
London in the eighties and nineties.
He was kind of the original bad boy,
if you will,
a pro tow Anthony Bordain in some ways
just like known for his aggressiveness
and um, and his sort of
brilliance and his creativity.
And I think he's just sort of this
like tortured bad boy kind of guy.
And so there's this beautiful
picture I saw of him on,
on this account called niche on
Instagram and this quote from him.
So he wrote, I believe there's
really two species of human beings.
The first species is the most common.
There's more of them.
They're individuals who like,
we all are born into a certain world
and they become a product of that world.
They absorb that environment they're born
into, they become an extension of it.
They become part of it. The
rarer species, in my opinion,
is the individual who has
been damaged as a child.
They have suffered
misfortune and great tragedy.
This doesn't mean that they're better
people, it just means they've suffered.
And very few individuals
suffer that tragedy.
But what happens is an
invisible shell covers you.
It protects you so you don't absorb
the world you're brought into.
You don't become part of that
world. You observe that world. Wow.
It was like exactly what you just said.
That's incredible.
And so it was really,
I mean,
and I don't know that my life has been
so dramatic to have been filled with like
that level of tragedy, but absolutely I
think even small pains and small traumas,
you know, or whatever, just like the
circumstances of our lives, you know,
can make us feel. And also the
whole idea of being an outsider.
Lately I've been thinking, I'm like, Oh
yeah, I've always felt on the outside,
but I'm like, does anyone really feel
on the inside? Like I don't know.
So I don't know.
But in terms of the beginner's
mind and that you know, that work,
I think I have to, there are two
sort of parts to that for me.
I think when I started
teaching people how to cook,
like I never forgot what it's,
what it felt like to be 19 years old
in a worldclass kitchen and not know
anything. I didn't know the difference
between Parsley and celery. So,
or parsley and Cilantro. I didn't
know personally and celery, but,
but you know, I didn't know anything.
I didn't know any fancy terms.
I didn't know even the most basic things.
Everything just was sort of
overwhelming and too much information.
And so I've never forgotten the feeling
of being so overwhelmed and lost and
having nothing to cling to.
And I feel like as long as I can
remember that and return to that,
every time I go to teach
or talk or write that,
then I'm really serving the people
that I'm trying to serve, which,
who are the people who don't know?
You know,
there are so many times where I had
to re set myself and remember I wasn't
writing my book or doing my work
to impress my peers. You know,
it's not for them. You know, it's not, uh,
also like their way their million
better chefs out there then, then me,
and I'm not out there
to compete with them.
I'm there to sort of be a translator
from the professional, you know,
for the amateur,
from the professional kitchen.
So if I can remember that and remember
the feeling of being the beginner,
then I can do my job right.
And as a writer, this, um,
the way I would say the person who really
has served as a model for me in that
more than anyone else is Michael Pollan.
And we're definitely going to
definitely get a dig into, into Michael.
Yeah. And so I talked to him, I talked
to him right after he recorded with you.
And He, yeah, he had such a great, great,
he just, I think like you blew his mind,
but, um, feeling is mutual.
I don't know how that guy
speaks and finished prose,
but maybe I'll figure it out.
But he,
um, he really taught me,
you know, and this wasn't
something he actively taught me.
I learned by reading his work and really
sitting with what it was that was so
moving and effective about
the way that he writes.
And it's that he is not,
um,
it's a old time timeworn journalistic
tool to put yourself in, you know,
to go do the experiential journalism.
He just has this incredible way of
immersing himself in really complicated
worlds and being able to
articulate them the war,
like what he's experiencing and what
he's learning in a way for anybody.
And so,
you know,
he did that with really
complicated things about GMO corn.
He did that with the botanical world.
He's done that with the
architectural world. And you know,
most recently he's done it
in the psychedelic world.
And so when I first sat down to write,
I was like, okay, I'm going to do this,
the Michael Pollan way.
And I tried to do what he would do,
which was to be this guide,
you know, this new, big guide.
But I realized that wasn't who I was,
you know,
what I needed to do was establish
some authority as a teacher.
So I couldn't take you on this
journey with me. You know, he's,
he's so good at doing it in a way where
he's not condescending at all and he's,
but yet he's so informative.
And so I really had to sort of sit with
that and let it distill through my bones
and through my mind and figure out how
can I take that kernel of not being
condescending of being really clear
and articulate of holding your hand and
bring you through here yet
also having some authority.
And so the best way that I found to do
that was to do what I did when I teach
people how to cook.
And when I talked to them,
which is to tell the stories
of when I didn't know anything.
And all of the 9,000 times I've messed
everything up because that is the closest
that I can be to being in your shoes as
a person who maybe doesn't know how to
deep fry, you know, or as afraid you're
going to burn your house down or whatever.
So,
um,
so ultimately I couldn't be Michael Pollan
and that's fine for both of us, but,
but I could learn from him and,
and really sort of put,
put some of his techniques into action
and we are going to revisit
that. Uh, because I'm,
I'm fascinated by writing process,
which really for people read it, uh,
for people reading,
if you're reading them this,
then I want to figure out how
you're achieving synesthesia.
But the listening to this writing process,
you can just substitute creative
process. It's same, same,
I mean same with experimenting in
the kitchen. Same with you name it,
composing new music.
But you had mentioned age 19 and I,
this might be a good
segue to the question.
How did you first get
exposed to Alice Waters?
Um,
so the very first time I ever heard of
Alice Waters was when I moved to Berkeley
in 1997 to attend college.
And at my freshman orientation
somebody was like, oh.
And there's a famous restaurant
with a famous chef in town.
And to me,
coming from San Diego,
eating mostly home cooked food and
sometimes fish tacos and Mexican food and
Chinese food or whatever.
There was no,
I had no concept of what a fancy
restaurant or a famous chef was.
So that sort of went in
one ear and out the other.
And then the following year I fell
in love and my boyfriend was from San
Francisco and we spent all of our time,
like all of our free time eating.
Yeah, totally. And so
he took me, you know,
to his favorite ice cream place and his
favorite pizza place and all of the sort
of childhood places. And he had
always wanted to go to Chez Panisse.
And so I still didn't really
know what it was and I,
but we decided to save. We
just, I knew it was expensive,
so we saved $220 over the
course of seven months.
And we, um, there's a
whole thing where it,
you have to reserve your table at
Chez Panisse a month in advance.
But the menu which has fixed only
is published a week in advance.
And so I was not yet a really
adventurous eater, you know,
and the definitely things,
so we did this complicated thing where
we reserved for like four nights in a row
and then when the menu was published,
we,
we chose the one we wanted and canceled
all the other ones because the menu is
different each day. Yeah. It's different
each night. And so I was like, Ooh,
that one looks like it,
you know? And so then we,
so then we went in and
I was, yeah, I was 19.
I was wearing a black
tank top and denim skirt.
We were very out of place in this
very probably a Berkeley is fanciest
restaurant. Um, I,
I think everyone probably knew
that we were not regulars. And, um,
and we had this really special meal and
I grew up eating really delicious food.
So it wasn't that this food was like
the most amazing thing I'd ever eaten.
It was just the entire experience was
unlike any I had ever had in a restaurant.
I really felt like I was at somebody's
house and they were caring for me and
they were so attentive to everything.
You know,
the bread and butter was never empty.
The water was never empty like the, the,
the plate.
The second we were done was whisked away.
There was just this sort of attention
that I had never received in a restaurant
before. And I think that
really got me. And, um,
so when the dessert came,
it was a chocolate souffle and I,
the server asked if I had ever
had souffle before and I said no.
And she said, would you like me to show
you how to eat it? And I said, yes,
please. Sure. And so she said, well,
you poke a hole with your spoon in the
top and then you pour the slim like
raspberry sauce in.
And that way every bite has sauce.
So I did that and I took a bite and
she said, how is it? And I said, oh,
it's really good,
but it would be a lot better
if I had a glass of cold milk.
And I had no idea that it was like so
rude to tell this person and this fancy
restaurant what would make my thing
better. You know, like I, you know,
and also I had no idea that in
fancy, you know, dining fine dining,
it's considered like a total full
pause to drink milk after 10:00 AM.
That's why in Italy if you order a
Cappuccino after 10:00 AM they know you're
American cause only babies
drink milk after 10:00 AM.
So this idea of like,
so like even having like the idea of
like asking for milk with chocolate after
dinner is like so gross to you know,
to people and fancy food. And so,
um, she kind of laughed. She was like,
you want to milk? And I was like, yeah,
like hello hot chocolate.
Then cold milk like good combo.
And so she went and she brought me milk
and then she also brought us each a
glass of dessert wine to sort
of teach us the refined to come.
Amen. And there was this really
sweet gesture. If you get,
once you've enjoyed your cold milk,
you may want to sample another option.
It was just this really, I don't
know, it was like a little education.
And so I was so moved by this whole
experience and this whole dinner that I
wrote this letter to Alice
Waters and I said, Oh, you know,
I brought it in a few months later
asking for a job as a busser.
And so I always had sort of like a basic
job that I worked throughout college.
So I brought it in and they said,
oh,
you have to bring that
to the floor managers.
So they led me to the four managers
office and when she opened the door,
it was the souffle lady. And
so, so she remembered me.
I think I, you know, in retrospect,
I think she was probably really
desperate because she was like,
you want to start tomorrow?
So I started,
I started the next day and
pretty immediately I was
just so enchanted by what
was happening in the kitchen and
that I just, I wanted to learn,
I wanted to learn what those people knew.
I mean,
that restaurant really exists like a
pyramid and the cooks are at the top.
They're the most respected, most
skilled people who work there. And, um,
I wanted to, I wanted that, you know,
I was so attracted to that with,
what did the letter say that
you wrote to? Oh Man, I'm Amy.
Do you remember any of it?
Because you have
your letter thing as far as I can
tell him the homework that I've done.
But do you recall at any of the
elements of that letter? Sure.
I use the word magical.
It's a very similar,
it's a very like semi word is I'm like,
I had a magical dinner at
your magical restaurant
and I was so inspired.
And I also don't think Alice
Waters ever saw that letter,
I think at like stopped with the
foreign manager probably. But, um,
I had never worked in a restaurant.
I'm sure I revealed that,
that I was just so moved
by this incredible dinner
that I wanted to work there.
And could I please have an opportunity?
I think it was a pretty
straightforward one.
I'm pretty good with like the flattery.
I would say that's like an important part
of these letters in my life where I've,
where I've like, you know, I'm writing
to someone cause I'm a huge fan and um,
and I'm like looking to collaborate
or for some opportunities.
So I start like really with like
laying it on thick, you know?
And I mean it's genuine
but like, and then, um,
and then I do my big ask and so yeah,
I had Dallas waters letter.
Then years later I had
the Michael Pollan letter.
Let's pause on the Michael
Paul, sorry. This is please,
please says sort of time and place when
you get a letter to Michael Pollan.
Oh, I'm in when? When's the
letter to Michael Pang? So, oh,
so that was you about 10 years
later? About 10 years later. Yeah,
almost 10 years later,
I was working at a different restaurant
in Berkeley and I saw Michael Pollan's
name in the reservation book
and I was a huge fan of his.
And I had met him a couple of times that
shape a niece. And he was, he, you know,
he'd been involved with Alice and,
and her work,
like their work really
sort of intersected.
And so they were big supporters of
one another. And I remember, you know,
before botany of desire came out
that like for whatever reason,
we had a copy of a galley
at shape and he said,
we were passing around and
eat and reading. And I was
like, who is this person?
This is amazing.
And so since I had read that book,
I had been a veracious reader
of anything that he wrote.
And I really admired the way that he was
an advocate and so eloquent about the
things that I care so deeply
about and, and work on. And,
um,
and so to me,
he was somebody who I really looked
up to also because even though I began
cooking, I never let go of the
idea of wanting to be a writer.
Like I always wanted to be a writer
since way before I was a cook.
And that was something that I
really kept pursuing in small ways,
even as I was cooking.
And so by the time that Michael Pollan's
name appeared in our reservation book,
I had applied to a few different creative
writing programs and gotten in and
deferred and never taken a leap.
And I knew that he was teaching at
the UC Berkeley School of journalism.
So I wrote this, I like quickly
scrawled out this card saying, you know,
I'm your number one fan.
Um, you mean so much to me.
I would love to come audit one
of your classes. And you know,
basically that it wasn't even a
super big letter. But then, um,
I gave it to the servers and I went home
that night and I asked them to give it
to him when he was eating.
So then, you know, they did.
And then a few weeks later,
I mean, this speaks so directly to
who Michael is. He wrote me back,
he wrote me an email and said, why don't
you come in and talk to me? And so, um,
he wrote me back.
I went in to go talk to him and I asked
him to audit his class and he said,
you know,
it might be a little bit tricky because
a lot of people want to audit the class
and, and, and, and so he's
like, but there's one spot,
there's one extra spot, so why don't
you come on the first day and we'll,
you know,
you guys can all vie for that spot.
So I showed up first they have this tiny
class and there was like 11 people in
the class, I think. And I think over
200 people showed up for that last spot.
And so,
um,
and so we each had to write an
index card saying why we w you know,
why we wanted to audit. So we
did. And then we went away.
And later that day I was lamenting to
my friend that there was no way that I
would ever get the spot. And my
friend said, don't you know anything,
don't you know anything about academics?
And I was like, I don't, I don't tell me.
And she said,
you need to write him right now and say
that he needs to give you this precisely
because you are a cook and you
will bring a different, you know,
you will bring a different viewpoint into
this class and the conversations will
be different because you're
from the inside of this world.
Because the class was about,
it's called following the food chain
and it was about the food industry.
And so I did that even though it felt
so wrong to write to Michael Pollan and
tell him that what he needed to do,
you know,
like from, you know, some 23 year old
or whatever. I Dunno, I would hold,
I was 29 maybe. But, um, so I did. And he,
he was like, okay. Like it
was so simple and we're like,
you know,
I asked,
I did the thing that I was so scared to
do and I asked and then that led to me
auditing this class,
which ended up being a really
incredible and pivotal moment for me.
But I, I don't know that I could've
put my finger on at that time.
But now I look back at it
and it's not only when I got,
got to work with Michael and what led
to, you know, us working together, um,
on writing and cooking,
but also I am,
became part of an incredible community
of journalists and writers and which is a
thing I had always wanted by then.
I had a really vast network of
cooking people and I was part of a,
an incredible cooking world,
but I didn't have a community at
all to support me as a writer.
I didn't know what a pitch was.
I didn't know anything about writing.
I didn't know articles are
measured in words, you know,
I didn't know any of that.
So I learned a lot of that,
not only from that class,
but also just from being around these
people and having peers who I could ask
all these questions of. And now
I work in an office, you know,
shared writing space with so many of
those people I've gone on to collaborate
with them. We, you know, they're,
they're my community who I am
constantly sort of reaching out to.
And now I'm able to
support in my own ways.
And so that was a really
important thing that I asked for.
Well, let's, let's look at the nitty
gritty of that. So you start with a,
a note in the restaurant that says,
I'm your biggest fan.
Can I audit your class? It w. W. W were
there any other ingredients in that note?
I'm going to, I'm going
to hit, I'm going to hit,
oh, it was a card. So it wasn't,
I remember that it was a card.
It was not like a letter on paper that
was folded card. Like hallmark card.
Are we talking about business
cards? Yeah. Like I went to the,
I think because on the street
where that restaurant was,
there was a couple of stationary stores.
So I think I bought a card, like a, yeah,
like a Ho, like some sort of greeting
card. So I, it wasn't so long.
Whatever I wrote, I think I just,
I think really it said like,
my name is [inaudible]. I'm
a huge fan of yours. Um,
I have always wanted to write. I really
would like to call it at your class.
Um, it would be so mean. It would be,
it would mean so much to me. I mean,
they're honestly, I don't know why.
There's no reason why Michael Pollan,
I'm not sure you're giving yourself
enough credit. So that's, that's,
that's part one, part two.
He, he writes you back,
you show up.
It's like the gladiatorial games with
200 competitors and you write in the next
card. Do you remember any of
what you put on the index card?
I don't. Oh man, I
don't remember that. No.
So then your friend says,
Hey, don't you know anything
about academics? No, I don't.
Just tell me you need to write this.
And so you send this followup email.
Do you remember like subject line?
Anything else that you put in that email?
Uh, no. Should I see if it's
in my, I don't know if I
had this email address then
I search for my oldest emailed him.
I bond right now.
Well, you know what, we
could, we could look at it, we
could, uh, I could look it up.
You get it to me later and I can,
if you find it,
I'll put it in the show notes for people.
I think the thing for me is that
I know that I'm very verbose,
so anytime I sit down to ask
for something, I think, um,
and I intuitively knew this before
and now I know it really clearly and
articulate it to myself and other people,
which is like if you're writing an email
to somebody to ask them for something,
just get to it, you know, don't
beat around the bush. And so and so.
I don't need your whole backstory.
Like I don't need the booboo booboo.
We would just like say the thing.
So I'm pretty sure I did that one pretty
tightly because we were already in this
conversation and
me and the class,
because I'll bring,
yeah, because I'm broke
and I have this, you know,
and I work in the sustainable
food world and I'm going to bring,
because what he had told me,
I sort of glossed over this before,
but what he had told me when I had come
to his office hours before I went to
that first day of class was he said,
listen,
I know you want to take this class but
it's never going to happen because I have
obligations to a long list of people.
And you're at the very end of that list.
Because first my obligations are to the
students of this graduate school and
then of the other graduate schools of UC
Berkeley and then to the undergraduates
of UC Berkeley and then the community.
And so there are so many other like
paying students ahead of you that you are
low priority to me.
I mean he didn't do it in a mean way,
but it was just like he was telling
me, telling me what it was. And so,
but he was like, but if you want, you
can come to to this day. So I did,
I saw it in action.
The fact that there were so many people,
I also think he's a softie at heart even
though he's like comes across as a rule
follower. So even though there were only
supposed to be 12 people in that class,
I think there ended up being 15
of us, you know, and so, so, um,
but,
but yeah,
I don't think if I had not followed
up with that email and, and said,
listen,
like you need me precisely because I'm
not one of those people further up on
this list. Um, that, that,
that was why, you know,
I was so enthusiastic and in,
in sort of since the class,
like during the class and since the class,
it became really apparent that
I did do it precisely that,
that I did bring a viewpoint that
nobody else in that room could have.
And I helped arrange for us a field trip,
you know,
to this like wackadoodle sustainable farm.
And there were ways where,
because I had an insider's perspective,
I could connect other students with like
the kinds of stories that they probably
wouldn't be able to find on their own
because I was living it, you know,
and immersed in it. So I don't
think he regrets it. I hope not.
So we're talking,
we're talking about a writer who's had
a big influence on your writing your
career.
Let's backstep for a second to two
books that have had a big impact on you.
And, uh, in the course
of doing my, my homework,
I don't know when this came about,
but you can't believe everything
you read on the Internet,
so feel free to correct.
Okay.
But a list of books that the
shape and he's chefs gave you,
or was this something that
came up and then there were,
there were a few folks who came up,
I guess, uh, Marcel has on patients.
Gray could,
could you describe how that
list got to you and what were,
what were some of the books on that
list that had a big impact on you?
For sure. I mean, those are also
just cookbooks. So I have other,
other books I can talk about too. If
you want both. Both. Let's do both
then you can do in,
in whatever order you like.
Yeah.
But in terms of the,
that have been deeply formative
I think I don't before.
So one of the incredible things
about [inaudible] is that,
and this is absolutely
comes from Alice and the,
and the world that she's created
is she is an artist above all else.
And so she really surrounds herself with
deeply creative people and artists of
all different kinds.
And so food is just one part of this
lifestyle that she really tries to create
and teach people and
immerse people in. And, um,
so beautiful writing
is a big part of that.
And I think I had a pretty limited
exposure to cook books before I came to
[inaudible] where I just knew them as
the thing that you look up the recipe in
to make for dinner.
And so when I begged the chefs
there to teach me how to cook,
you know, and just to like set
the scene at the time was about,
I think this was 2000,
um,
the restaurant kept winning,
you know,
best restaurant in America
from Gourmet magazine,
which at the time was like the biggest
sort of, um, award of its type.
And so it really,
if there,
there was no reason for these chefs to
let me into the kitchen. There was a line,
a mile long of much more experienced
people than me trying to get this job.
And I knew that and they knew that.
Everyone knew that. And so, um,
I knew nothing and I,
all I had was my enthusiasm really and
my dedication and like my work ethic.
So I,
I asked the chefs what I needed to do
in order to earn an unpaid apprentice
ship. Like if that's what I was
competing for. And, and they said,
you need to cook every day.
You need to watch these cooks
everyday day you're here,
you need to learn how to taste and develop
your palette and you need to go home.
And read all these books and they gave
me a stack of like probably 30 bucks.
I mean,
they didn't actually give me the books.
They told me about 30 bucks to read.
And so they're like,
these are the books that are the
shape and east canon and things like.
There were books, there were books
unlike anything I had ever seen.
So patients gray, who
was an incredible, um,
incredible writer in the mid century
who traveled with her husband throughout
like Turkey and Greece and Italy.
And Spain wrote this beautiful book called
the hunting from a weed that is just,
it's like a poem. And yes,
there are recipes with like
cups and measures in there,
but there is just a way that
sort of one country to the next,
she connects all these dots and it's
so beautiful and moving and it's,
it's put together writing and food in
a way unlike I had ever seen before.
And so that was a really, really formative
book for me. There was another one,
kind of in the same vein called,
um,
the [inaudible] bears of the flowering
hearth by a person named Roy Andrews.
De Groot, I think it's his pen
name. And this, this one was a,
like if a novel met a cookbook kind of,
because it was an imaginary world that
this guy had sort of created about this
like Magical,
oh bears somewhere in the mountains and B,
which is like a,
like a,
like a mountain hotels
somewhere in France. Yeah.
And so, um, and a mountain
in a country in I guess like,
uh,
you know,
and so there were just these kind of
like beautiful narratives that were
intertwined in talking about food
that were so moving to me. Um,
and then there were the basic cookbooks
that I had to learn, you know,
history and tradition and
culture from things like, um,
Richard old knees writing and yeah.
Martella Hassan and S.
Oh gosh.
I mean all of the shape
and ees books. So, um,
it was really a kind of a world that I
had never been exposed to because we at
my house had,
um,
growing up we had two Persian
cookbooks are culinary tradition,
was entirely oral.
And then we had like a sesame street
cookbook that had a banana bread recipe
that I used to make when I was little.
And that was about it.
There was not this like deep tradition
of cookbooks that I grew up around.
So this was a really moving an
influential thing for me. And then,
um, yeah, writing wise
I have read, I mean,
so many, I read so much
nonfiction. I mean, I love, love,
love John McPhee. I love, love. Yeah.
I mean to me I've learned so much
about structure from John McPhee.
So do you have a favorite one or two
favorites filled levels of the game
to all people? If you read the book
description, people who are like,
what's an entire book on a
single tennis match? Trust me.
And trust is so good. It's so good.
And it really taught me that, you know,
there was a period where I was like,
maybe I write my book,
like the levels of the game and I
find a way to tell a story. You know,
there's just, he is a master of
structure and I find, you know,
I for me a challenge as a writer and
also as as now just like a creative
thinker,
probably one of the most thrilling
things for me that I am so excited by,
but also to intimidated by his coming up
with structure for things. And so, and,
and in being in search of
always like the simplest,
most elegant structure and I feel like
you can convey information so much more
clearly when a structure,
um,
is right and, and simple, you
know, and so, and it's fun.
It's a fun practice.
Right now I'm figuring out like if I'm
going to do another show and I've, and,
or another book and I think I figured out
an idea. And so now I'm just like, okay,
how do I structure it? So it's just
that kind of stuff where I, I love,
I love those.
And very randomly,
this book I saw one day at a
store when I was struggling,
like on the 900th the draft of my own
book and it has been so meaningful and
moving to me.
It's called several short sentences
on writing and it's by a writer named
Verilyn Klinkenborg who teaches at Yale.
And he used to have a column in the
New York Times, I think it was called,
like on rural living where,
and he's written about writing.
And the entire point of this whole small
book is make your sentences shorter and
it really is so good.
If one is to look at your bio,
it's a very impressive bio,
right being called the next Julia Child
by empires, all things considered,
you're in New York Times best selling
author, you have this TV show,
you have all of these various accolades
and I think it's easy for someone
perhaps to look at that be
very intimidated and uh,
assume that you've just been getting
up at bat and hitting home runs,
uh, since, since, since you
began one after the other.
So if you'd be open to it,
I'd love to talk about failures,
whether those are failures, failures
that set you up for later success.
And of course those people who've read
Trump's mentors will recognize this
question or heard the podcast.
I like to ask this question in
terms of like a favorite failures,
past failures that really taught you
something that seemed like a failure,
but in fact if they hadn't
happened something else,
which was a success wouldn't
have happened later.
Can you give us any examples that sa
there's so many options here.
Um, yeah. I mean I was just,
I was thinking, you know, I
came really close to writing to,
to cowriting two other books before
I ended up writing my own book.
And though neither of those felt right,
but I was just so desperate to work on
a book that I almost did those ones.
And I kind of messed up both of those
opportunities and I felt really bad.
Like I would never get an
opportunity to write my own book.
And if I had done those, I don't think
that I, how did you mess them up?
If you don't mind me? Um, well, um,
well the one that I can
remember more clearly was, um,
it was going to be a book about pickle and
specific it was going to be a book about
pickling and I was going to do it with
a friend and there was a way where I,
um,
we met with this agent of book literary
agent who had brought the idea to her.
And, um, sometimes I just
didn't, I don't know,
I couldn't have put my finger on it, but
to me at that time I was like an agent,
like that's a high powered, you know what
I mean? Only fancy people have agents.
And so I felt like I needed to prove
myself to this agent and there was
something about like,
our relationship just didn't feel
right and I don't know that I,
I don't think I trusted her
completely and I felt really, um,
kind of put down by her. It just
didn't feel very good. And so I think,
I can't, this was so long ago, I
can't remember exactly what happened,
but I think I like inelegantly
extracted myself from that.
Like I had committed to it and then I,
and committed because I just didn't
feel like it was the right thing.
And then I just worried like,
oh no,
does this mean I'll never find an
agent or I'll never get to do a book.
So that was one I'm trying to remember.
And then,
um, then, oh, there was actually another,
another age man, I have like really have
like a trail of burnt agents behind me.
Um,
there was another agent
who came to me and um,
and again,
she made me feel like I needed to prove
myself to her and that my ideas weren't
that good. And I had this one idea
and she didn't want me to do that.
And she found me.
I used to do these dinners,
uh,
at tartine bakery in San Francisco,
which is its own cult place.
And so because of that, these
dinners that I had, it was called 13,
after hours became like this other,
it became a little cult thing.
And so in a very small world,
it was a very popular thing.
And so I think she sort of was in that
world. And so she found me through that.
And um,
there was just a way,
I think what it was was I,
yeah,
I've never actually spent
the time to think about it,
but in both of those situations,
the relationships,
the fundamental primary relationship,
which at that time was with the agent,
like it wasn't so much with an editor
yet or anything. It just was so, um,
on uneven ground.
And it was this thing where I was
struggling to prove myself as a creative
thinker to them. And um, it was just,
I didn't very much feel supported and
that is not a great place for me or maybe
for anyone from which to
do your best creative work.
I've learned that for
sure in my career now as,
as a writer whose worked with so
many different kinds of editors.
Like my current editing situation at the
Time magazine is so wonderful because
my editor,
I love her so much and she knows
exactly how they lay it to me.
Like she tells it to me straight,
you know,
she knows how to give me a
smack down when I need it.
But she also is so kind and supportive.
And so there's just this very fundamental
trust that we have where I used to
turn stuff into her every,
every month, my column.
And I would have like a one page apology
that I would write this like college,
email the fort with the, with
each draft. And she was like,
you have to stop sending these apologies.
This is insane.
Like you're doing your best.
I know you're doing your best.
I also know you're not
going to phone it in.
And also the stuff you're turning in
is not bad. So stop apologizing. So,
but I had sort of,
um,
there's just been all so many
different experiences I've had where,
where I have been made to feel like I'm
dumb or I'm not trying hard enough and I
actually, I'm trying so hard, you know?
And so I now have learned
from my own self that I, I,
I need to be smarter and very careful
about what kind of creative collaborations
I enter because I need a kind of a
relationship that's vulnerable and open.
And it's not that I don't want criticism.
I actually do want your criticism
because I do want to make it better,
but how do you convey that to me,
you know,
and also do we have a fundamental trust
between the two of us that were both,
you know,
that we both are aiming
toward the same goal of,
you know, making the best
possible thing. So I think, ah,
I don't know. I, sorry, I've completely
veered away from your original question,
but I'll be,
I'll be the guide rails.
I want to actually hone in on something
that you said about your editor at the
Times who can deliver the smack down,
but do so with a delivery that you find
very palatable that you do want the
criticism,
but it's a,
it's a question of it being constructive
and delivered in the right way.
Can you give any examples of,
of how that editor might
deliver criticism or it can,
it can be a hypothetical made up example
or just what makes it so walk that,
uh, you know, thread the needle of
being both affective criticism but,
but not making you
defensive or deflating you?
Um, yeah. I wish I had
a very specific example,
but I can set the emotional tone of it,
which is that there is, we have developed,
I mean it's been over a year now
that we're in constant contact.
So we have at this point developed an
understanding that I know that she wants
the best for me and she knows
that I'm always gonna do my best.
And so if she tells me something,
even in shorthand sometimes,
now she does this thing where
she just writes, do better.
And so now I know, okay, like that's a
phrase that I need to do better, you know,
or it's not working.
Like I think so much of it isn't an
emotion as like a fundamental, um, um,
the emotional work that we had done
earlier and that had come through these
vulnerable exchanges where I, where
I had said to her, I'm really sorry.
And she said, listen, I
know you're doing your best.
So once I was able to trust her
in that way, I think I have,
I've let go of a lot of the defensiveness.
I'm trying to think of some of the early,
she was a lot more gentle in the beginning
and I think that had a lot to do with
it.
She was very gentle and she would,
she would sort of write out more complete
sentences about why something was
overexplaining or,
or maybe like tube too, I don't
know, snobby or whatever. She,
so I think she really did
the work initially to allow
me to trust her and feel
safe with her. And then that now we
have a such a nice shorthand where like,
I can just be like, can you just
do this, you know, or whatever.
Yeah. I'll keep it short and sweet.
Before, before you came to writing though,
we've talked about the cowriting,
uh,
opportunities which did not manifest or
that you extricated yourself from and
then ultimately having
the opportunity to do,
to write the type of book
that you want to write it.
Do you have any failures or missteps
from what proceeded that I assume or,
yeah, like the, uh, from the culinary
world or restaurant world or otherwise?
Yes. So many. I mean, I would say the
two biggest failures of my career,
our culinary, um, and they,
they sit and beautiful
contrast to one another.
So one of them was I helped
run a restaurant for five
years that was struggling
financially the whole
time it existed. And, um,
there was a way where it
was not my restaurant. I was
helping my mentor run it.
I felt very loyal to him. And in
the beginning I had, you know,
like restaurants are often, um, lose
money for up to five years, you know,
before they sort of hit.
It's a, it's really just a
terrible financial models. So,
so there's a way where like they,
they often lose money for a long time
before they sort of hit steady ground.
And we actually hit steady ground
after three years. But then in 2008,
the economy crashed.
And so it was sort of just this
thing where we weren't going to,
we knew we were never going to make it
okay. And there were a lot of sort of,
I think community,
there was a culture issue
in that restaurant that um,
now with so many years of distance I can
see it was almost insurmountable and,
and if a culture and a place
isn't sort of support there,
it's really hard to turn the
culture of a place around I think.
And so in some ways to me
I was ready to like cut it,
call it quits after three years,
but for my mentor,
this was like his big shot that his
career had been working, you know,
aiming toward and he wasn't
ready to give up. So I,
I stayed for two years longer than I
wanted to and I was really unhappy.
I was really unhealthy, like
just physically at really. Um,
I feel like it took a toll on my adrenal
system. I had a really bad temper.
This was right, you know, write book.
This was eventually like led to the
breakdown that led me going to therapy.
Like I was emotionally just out of touch.
I was not that kind to the people
who worked for me. It was not great.
It was not my greatest hour.
And so I think staying through something
and feeling how bad that made me feel,
how bad it made other people feel and
that it ultimately sort of fizzled to the
slow,
painful death really taught me that I
don't ever want to be part of that kind of
situation again. Like I want to be the
one calling, calling quits, you know,
I want to be the one who like
determines the end of a story.
And when I think about it, you
know, in any creative project,
which even or business probably in some
ways a business is not so different from
a creative project. Like things have a
beginning, a middle and an end. You know,
like even when people sit down to
write a movie, to write a series,
even if you want to pitch
a TV series, um, you know,
an ideal life span for a TV
series is five to seven years.
And so before you even start, you know
how the series is going to end, right?
Like there's a way where
it's not a bad idea.
An ending is not necessarily a failure.
And so I really got to put
that into practice a couple
of years later when after
the restaurant closed,
I started this like kind of small food
market that immediately became a huge
success and got so much media
attention and all of a sudden was um,
I started it because I just missed
cooking for people and I wanted to cook a
little bit in my spare time while I
was figuring out how to be a writer.
And then all of a sudden all of
my time and resources and energy,
we're going toward
running this food market.
That wasn't even the main thing I
wanted to accomplish in my life.
And so even as it grew and we got more
followers and more customers and we're
making more money or whatever,
I knew that it wasn't what I wanted to do.
So instead of letting
that also fizzle out,
I ended after two years and people
really wanted like all the food media was
like, what's the gossip? Why
is this closing? I was like,
it's not closing. You
know, nothing's wrong.
Like I'm just closing it cause I
want to do something else. And so
sudden easy decision, a hard decision. I
like walk us through, I don't know the,
the, the like the weeks before
making it official. This is
okay. Yeah. So, so, so I knew in,
in one way it wasn't easy decision because
my gut told me that I didn't want to
do it.
In practical terms,
it was much more difficult because
there were a lot of people who I felt
responsible to who relied on this
market for their income. And so, and,
or they thought they relied on
the market for their income.
And so there was a story that we all
were telling about how important to this
market was in all of these people's lives.
And I feel,
I have very maternal instincts.
Like I feel a lot of responsibility
for the community that I create and,
and to them. And so if
anything, I want to,
I felt a need to stay for them
rather than for myself. And,
um, and that was really brutal. And around
this time I was like really into yoga,
like super into yoga and,
and when you go to yoga class,
like often what they talk
about is setting an intention.
And so I was really like doing
a lot of yoga talk and um,
and I had this thing where I realized
that because my career was so a morphous
because there wasn't some like other
person on whose career I was modeling my
own, there wasn't an easy way for me to
know that I was moving. I don't know,
in the right direction toward anything
I wanted to actually accomplish. Right.
There weren't like these landmarks of
like, when you want to be a doctor,
you do this, this and this and this. When
you want to be a lawyer, you do this,
this and this. And so I didn't
have that. So how did I,
I was on the right track to where I
wanted to go and I really started to hone
this thing for myself, which was, well
since I don't know where my ultimate, um,
ending point is,
are my ultimate goal is I,
what I do know is that it's a feeling I
have a feeling in my belly that I want
to work toward and so,
and that and that when an opportunity
comes to me or a professional decision
comes to me,
I can think about it in terms of
if I say yes or no to this thing,
will it take me closer to or farther away
from this feeling that I tried to feel
and also create in the world.
And so probably the biggest conflict in
deciding to close that market was that
that feeling has a lot to do with
community and supporting people.
And I knew that closing,
closing the market would sort
of temp in the short term,
maybe like take me farther away from that.
But I also had to flip fundamentally
believe that it would give me the space to
like in a different way. On a
larger scale, go back toward that.
So a few questions relate to that.
Why was the food market so quickly popular
or were there any particular reasons
that uh, that come to mind? I think
part of it was timing of it. Um,
so what was was I was really good
at making pasta. That's like,
I lived in Italy for two years.
I Made Pasta every day for 10 years.
I really love making Pasta and um,
and so people,
when the restaurant closed,
I would sort of bump into people
in town and they'd be like, well,
we really miss your pasta. And
so, and I really enjoy that,
like beautiful sort of manual labor of
making it and the folding and the cutting
and the whole thing. And
so, um, I thought, well,
what if I cut out all of the parts of
having a restaurant that I hate and I just
make the pasta and sell it to people.
So we had,
I had these friends who had a commercial
kitchen that was empty a lot of
evenings, so they let me use
it. And I was like, okay,
well how do I sell this pasta to people?
So this was,
I think it was 2009 so it was before,
I think it was before Instagram or it
was certainly before Instagram was really
big and I maybe had a Twitter
with like five followers.
But like really Facebook was
the main thing that I used.
And so I think I put on Facebook
like I'm in a cell, some pasta,
does anyone buy it? And I made a Google
doc and people started buying it. And so,
um,
we had the,
I opened a little like Shopify storefront
where people would order the stuff
online and then I would know exactly
how much to make because it was a big
thing.
And food is like,
if it's already so hard to make money
and really if you're not efficient in
terms of every decision of
how much labor and ingredient,
you'll really lose money.
So by sort of taking my orders in advance,
I knew exactly how much to make and
nothing was going to go to waste and then
people would come pick up their stuff.
And so then very quickly it grew from
just pasta to pasta and sausages to pasta
and sausages and cookies.
Cause everyone else that I knew who was
an unemployed cook who maybe wanted to
start their own food business also
wanted to do these things. So we,
we started doing this and all of a sudden
it became this like online marketplace
where you could preorder your and prepaid
for your food and then come and pick
up your stuff like a week later.
I know it was sort of this way
to get beautiful restaurant
quality stuff at home,
but it was before,
it was certainly before caviar.
It was certainly before like a
lot of these internet food things.
And it was also before good eggs,
which is like a food tech startup
that was sort of born out of,
of this thing.
Um,
and so it was definitely like one
of the first online like I dunno,
order your food thing. I don't
know. It was just a weird time.
And so then we had a mailing list from
the restaurant and I started sending it
out to that.
And very quickly because of the press
sort of was like very interested in this
weird way that I was operating this thing,
the mailing list grew to like,
you know, many, many tens of thousands
of people way more than I could support.
And so it was just,
it was,
it was a whole thing that grew out of
control beyond the resources I had very
quickly.
And so I was always struggling to keep
up and that became such a source of
stress and all I had wanted
to do was to make some pasta
and I'm like managing like 9,000
business licenses and permits and health
department and you know,
sh taxes and sales tax.
There was just like an vendors and vendor
infighting and people wanting their
beans Vegan or whatever.
Like it was so much more
than I ever wanted to do and
it took so much energy and
I couldn't do it anymore and I knew,
I knew I couldn't do it anymore.
So you have, see you have this
feeling, I can't do this anymore,
which I think a lot of people have and
yet they keep doing it right for a long
time and maybe, maybe forever. Uh, it,
it to a certain extent
now while this is happening,
you have these maternal instincts kicking
in your which make you feel obligated
on some level to uh,
help these people who at least in your
head at some point and in their heads
depend on this income.
When do you remember like the meal,
the drinks you had with a friend,
the walk you took where you're just like,
you know what, fuck it. Like I have to,
I have to say hello.
I have to close this down.
When you went from thinking about winding
it down to like, okay, tomorrow morning,
like that's it,
I'm doing it.
Therapy. Okay. All right.
I'm pretty sure it was therapy
and I'm pretty sure I realized,
I think the like thought that sort of
like really hit my body that I realized,
um,
it was that I had by that
point spent 10 years cooking.
I had been wanting to be a writer for,
you know,
since I was 15 years old.
Um,
I finally had a chance to like
make the time to be a writer.
I even had an office that I had
that I shared with other writers.
Like I had everything in place,
but because this thing was ruining
my life and making me miserable,
I couldn't do the thing that I always
had wanted to do and was like basically
ready to do.
And so,
and not that it was some easy thing to
just go be a writer because like what I
was going to write, I ended up writing
blog posts for Yoga journal.com for $25.
Like it wasn't so much income or
anything, it was just this, I had this,
I knew that this thing was making me like
emotionally and almost physically ill.
So I had, I just had to
stop. And I think, um,
in that now I'm just so much more
attuned to that moment to that feeling of
knowing like, this thing
is bad for me, you know?
And no matter how many other people,
it's a good for.
It's making me sick and it's
making me feel really bad.
So I think, um, I,
I try to be a lot more aware of that.
And sometimes now I get into situations
or projects or jobs where like I,
that feeling comes up again,
but I'm already in it.
And often now a lot of the work
that I do is temporary. You know,
like it's a one I'd make, I do one
project, I do one article, I do one story,
I do one, whatever. Um, so now
for me it's more about learning,
um, and being really attuned to what's
happening. Even just for example,
in the process of making the show,
like I had never made a show before.
This was this incredible
opportunity that came to me.
I was so excited and felt so lucky
to go make it and go do it. And,
um,
and I still feel so lucky and so excited,
but a lot of things happen throughout the
making of the show that I was like, oh,
this doesn't feel very good,
or this doesn't feel very fair.
Or I don't ever want to be in a
situation like this again, you know? And,
and so now that I know what this
situation, what, what's possible,
like I know that when negatively and also
positively I know what to ask for and
I know how to articulate
that. And so, you know,
like I will affirm ever insist,
you know,
like to me I'm going to insist on working
with a lot more people of color in the
future.
Like I'm going to insist on making sure
that I have a lot more power creatively
in anything that I do because I,
I realized I became very frustrated when
I didn't have as much power as I needed
or wanted. So, um,
there just things like it's a constant
learning thing. Nothing's perfect.
We figure things out as we go and,
and like we try to do our best and
like what is failure? I don't know.
I mean it's not that big of a deal if,
especially if there's some
sort of positive takeaway
that you have and maybe my
therapist would be really proud of me.
Maybe it's really bad me to even say
that my therapist would be proud of me,
but like,
but I do feel like all of these stories
and all of these experiences really
always come back to me sort of
paying attention to my feelings.
Yeah. Here, here, that's,
that's something that I've also personally
been been working on because I think
I muted my feelings are viewed them
as a liability for so long and I've,
I've realized Holy Shit,
you cannot spreadsheet your
way out of everything. No,
no. We're into everything. You
really have to pay attention to that.
I mean I came,
I think about that all the time.
Like I came from a culture that's like
very much about sort of appearances and
not very touchy feely and a lot of ways
I came from a family that wasn't super
touchy feely.
I came so like what did I learn to do?
I learned to shut down all of my
own feelings and then I made myself,
I made my way into a profession who
literally tells you to shut down your
feelings.
Like when you're a cook in a restaurant,
you don't have time or room or space
for feelings. Like, and not only that,
not only emotional feelings,
but if you actually burn or cut yourself,
there's not time or space to address that.
You just sort of wrap your
hand up and keep going.
So there's this way where like I have
been trying to unravel the many years of
sort of emotional shutdown that
I have been conditioned to be in.
And so now I'm like, I'm gone. I'm like
on way to the other end where I'm like,
what is the field? You know, I read
about Jill Soloway always sets and uh,
she's the director, the director and
creator of transparent. And I read about,
or the other day I was listening
to an interview with, um,
one of the actors from Atlanta and I
read about these TV sets where everyone's
real touchy feely and I'm like checks in
with each other all the time. And like,
they have an emotional check in
every morning. And, and I'm like,
that's the kind of place where I
want to work like that. I'm like,
I just want to work where
like the camera man is like,
and we are crying together.
You know,
if you are,
if you do have that experience,
I want to have a followup conversation
to see if you're like, okay,
that's my home. Or if you're like,
you know what, a pendulum swing
too far the other direction.
Like I think I want somewhere in the
middle I can only have half the camera
people crying.
Uh,
you,
you have tackled so many different
projects and so many different ways.
You've had some missteps,
a,
you've made your mistakes
as we all have a,
your book was,
I at least from the outside looking in a,
I mean,
a real flag in the ground that has
allowed you to do a lot of things.
And it's a very, very, uh, it's
a very good book. Like I said,
it's one of the few I keep in my kitchen
and I'd love to chat just a little bit
about the genesis because
I think it was what,
let's say around 2006 when
slip this note to pollen.
And when did, uh, when
did your book come out?
20, uh, La last year was last year. Yeah.
Plus your 2017. Okay. Yeah.
And this is not a book that you,
uh,
churned out really quickly.
You didn't just assemble another cookbook,
which you and I both know are everywhere.
Uh,
and,
and it did make a mark.
So I'm really curious to know you,
your auditing this class
with Michael Pollan,
what are some of the early ideas for the
book or really titles for the book that
never saw the light of day?
So after I audited the class with my goal,
he started writing a book about cooking,
which ended up being cooked.
So he asked me to teach him how to cook.
So when I would come over to his house,
we would cook together and
talk about cooking. And I,
every week when I went over there
I'd bring over a different book idea.
And there were smart, Ho, many
bad ones, so many bad ones.
Like, um, I can't remember all of them.
I do remember there was one where I had
this sort of mentee employee who was
kind of like this like,
um, bipolar gutter punk,
what is a gutter punk?
I got her punk is like a,
well we have a lot of
them in Berkeley. Um, he,
he was just this kind of punky kid who
was like, had all the tattoos and um,
and listen to like, you
know, like loud music.
I don't know, like he called
himself, I got her punk and so he,
and he had a lot of like
learning disability is an,
I had given up hope on him as an employee.
I don't even know why we hired him.
And eventually I just was like,
I give up such hope on him that
I couldn't look at him for.
I couldn't look him in the eye for months.
And at some point there was some moment
that he had where he turned himself
around and he came to work and suddenly,
I think it had to do with taking honestly
his, um, his mental health medication.
And so,
um,
and so he just like became
this incredible student and,
and I felt really bad for not having
been a better supporter of his,
but then I also became motivated to
really teach him and support him.
And this incredible moment was when he
came to work one day and he was like,
I don't want you guys to be
mad at me, but I, you know,
I've been going to community college and
I signed up for a study abroad program
and I'm going to Italy. Like I was
like, we are not mad at you. I was like,
this is the most amazing
thing that you like.
Somehow it went from basically being
nearly homeless when you started coming
here to caring about food so much that
you like sign yourself up for community
college,
you got yourself to go to Italy.
Like this is incredible and we're gonna
help you as much as we possibly can.
So he was really,
this I learned probably as much from
as he learned from me and I was like,
I'm going to write a memoir of teaching
Robin how to cook. And Michael was like,
that's a terrible idea. It was like
nobody wants to read them. And then,
and so then,
you know,
and then I had this other idea where
I was going to write the tartine after
hours cookbook cause they're like menu
cookbook of all these dinners that I had
made that I was making an in tartine
bakery. And Michael was like, you know,
and that's fine.
Like,
but I know you're thinking it's going
to be easy and no books are easy.
And eventually he would sit
down. Yeah. He's just like,
there's no such thing as an easy book
for. Yeah. And so, um, he said to me,
he was like, I, I know you. Oh,
he would interview me periodically so
to get quotes for his book. And he said,
what's the deal? You're so obsessed with
these four elements. And I was like,
oh yeah, salt, fat, acid, heat, you know,
that's the system that I
used to teach myself to cook.
I used to teach other people. I always
thought I'd write a book about it one day.
And he was like, well, there is your
book, write that. And I was like, no, no,
no, no, no. I was like, that book's
going to be really hard to write.
It won't have beautiful photos because
it's not about that kind of cooking.
And it just, I, I can't do
that. And he, he's, he just,
I remember this so
clearly. He said, listen,
like you live in a delusional
universe where everyone who you know,
who's written a successful book is
already a celebrity of some kind,
either a celebrity chef or
like some famous writer.
And so you have this really confused
notion that book and celebrity are somehow
like tied together or
notoriety or something.
But really what publishers want
is a unique and strong idea.
And that's what this is. I've never heard
this before. It makes so much sense.
And so this is your book. And he's like,
stop messing around and go do this.
And I was like,
right.
And so I just felt the weight of this
like huge task being set before me.
And, um, and so, you
know, and like I said,
I didn't really have the tools
in the beginning. I mean,
I sort of knew what went into a book,
went into a book proposal.
He sort of told me,
but I also knew that this was would look
much different than any book proposal
he had ever written.
And so I just sort of started
going to my office. I have got a,
I got a writing residency and
I went to go figure this out.
It was my first writing resident,
sorry.
It's just like,
uh,
it was like an opportunity to go
right for two weeks uninterrupted in,
in a beautiful setting and
like be housed and fed.
And that was maybe a mistake to go so
early in my writing process because I
wasn't really writing,
I was still very much like idiating.
So I just had like a wall of post it
notes and then everyone else at the
residency would come down to
the dinner table and be like,
I wrote 5,000 words today.
And I'd be like, yeah,
well I like, I always want
to slap those people. No,
no offense to anyone listening as
well as people. They're like, Oh man,
had a pretty tough day.
Only knocked out 5,000 words.
What I barely figured out,
which fought to use on the first page.
I like
laying in a hammock a lot.
And um, and that first round,
like anything I wrote during
those two weeks, I was,
that was definitely the time when I
was attempting to be Michael Pollan.
And so eventually I realized that
wasn't working for me. And so then,
and then I tried for a short while to
be another writer and then that wasn't
working either. And then eventually I
was like, oh, I just have to be myself.
Who the other, if you don't mind.
And it's my friend Tamara Adler,
who's an incredible writer.
She just has such a beautiful way of
writing that I very much enjoy reading,
but it's not me. So you
know, and so, and um,
and it's so good that I
want it to be my word,
but it's not my words.
And so I had to,
I had to just be okay with whatever
comes out of my mouth or on, you know,
under my page is,
is my thing.
And I'm still learning that
like there are so many times,
even when I got this get
column for The Times magazine,
which at the time when I started cooking
was really like the highest sort of,
I dunno, like writing that was
coming out about food. It was me.
It was like the thing that I had always
dreamt of was to be able to write the
food column for The Times magazine.
So I couldn't believe it when
it finally became my job.
And I still can't really believe it.
And I still have so much terror every time
I sit down to write it where I'm like,
this is going to be published in the
New York Times magazine. Oh my God.
Like I'm not smart enough for this.
And so I'm not good enough for this.
And so then, um, and there's this
way where sometimes I'll turn,
I'll just be lazy and I can't figure
out a different way to say something.
So I'll write the silly,
stupid way that I would say it.
And that's the stuff the
editors are always like, this
is amazing. You're so good.
And I, every time I'm like, oh, I thought
that's what you were going to cut.
Like there was this one time when I said
something like, hello, my name is Simien.
I basically wear it like,
hi,
my name is [inaudible] and I'm an
artisan bread hoarder, you know,
which is such a silly dumb thing to
say. And she was like, this is amazing.
And I was like, I don't, and so
eventually I had to ask her, I said,
why is it that you always like this
really silly stuff that's not crafted?
You know?
And she said,
because it's you and because you're
here because we like your voice.
And so the more true you can beat your
own voice, the better that is. And I said,
but isn't that like the
cheesiest possible stuff?
I figured he would cut all those like
dumb jokes that I make and she said,
you know, maybe if it came from
someone else we would cut it.
But when it comes from you,
it sounds so true to what,
how you would actually talk or what
you would actually write that we,
it makes sense for us to keep it and I
said it is how I actually talk. She said,
yeah,
so that's why we want it so I'm still
getting it through my head that the thing
that people value about me is me,
you know me trying to be of
MacArthur genius or whatever.
Right.
You mentioned,
you mentioned earlier how Michael said
to you something along the lines of
publishers are looking for
unique and clear ideas.
I just want to
take that and expand it a bit because
for people who are listening,
I would also say that what any
audience or potential audience,
the people out there who are part of your
tribe or who want the version of you,
that is the true you,
that you can put on the page also
want not just unique and clear ideas,
but they want a unique and clear voice.
And that I've had friends come to me
who have incredible stories and are well
spoken, but they say, I'm
not a writer. I can't write.
I don't know if I could
ever tell my story,
although people tell me I should write a
book, I should do this, I should do that.
And that's a longer conversation.
Like whether you should
write a book or not as is
most miserable. Four years of
your life. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
If it, if, if it, if,
if for whatever reason it exercises more
demons than like a year is it pulls out
of your life then. Yes,
but, but what, what, uh,
what I try to convey,
and this was set to me actually,
is that you don't need to be John McPhee.
You don't need to be Michael Paul.
You don't need to be,
uh,
anyone who's writing you admire
so much that intimidates you, uh,
to actually be a good writer, if
that makes any sense. Like if you,
if you have a unique and clear voice
and you can consistently be you,
then you've won more than half
the battle. And the SEC, if you,
if you don't know how to use a semi colon,
it's fine.
Not the most material
problem. Uh, and it's, uh,
I think you, you accomplish
that really well in your book.
And I would be curious to know as someone
who has dabbled in television a few
times now,
what did you find most
rewarding and challenging
about the television format and
it,
and why did you decide to say yes?
Because you go from a relatively solitary,
uh, queen of the castle environment.
When you're writing a book right now,
granted you have editors and so on,
but it's, it's kind of your Gig, right?
In a lot of ways to holy shit.
Who are all these people? What
am I going to do? Do I, how do I,
am I supposed to interact with everybody?
How do I meant it's,
it's completely different environment.
So why did you decide to do TV and,
and uh,
what were things that surprised you?
Well, in terms of this,
like solitary versus social,
I have always been both and which is
why I continue to cook because I really
enjoy both the manual,
like physical part of it,
but also the really communal part of it
where I get to go be in conversation and
ask other people what they're cooking and
eating and learn new things from other
cooks.
So I think I'd go bananas if I was
only sitting at a desk all day,
every day, you know? So I enjoy
having both things. So to me,
the decision to go work on some
collaboration that would bring me in to,
you know,
work with a lot of people all the time,
that really wasn't a
negative thing at all. Um,
and then, I don't know,
you know, I was so excited.
I um,
I was so excited about the opportunity
to bring this philosophy of cooking to a
broad,
broad audience that that was ultimately
the thing that I was seeking.
And to me,
I think after the first or second
cooking class I ever taught,
which I think was around 2006 or 2007,
I remember coming to work one day with
my friends with these other chefs and I
said, you know, this is really
inefficient. I was like,
here I am like teaching 12 ladies,
you know, 12 wealthy ladies how to,
I don't know,
use the right amount of salt or whatever.
Like how many of these 12 person cooking
classes I'm going to have to teach
before I actually teach people,
you know,
a really a broad audience.
How this kind of fundamental and
really life changing information.
It seems like it's going to be
hard to reach a large crowd.
Plus just the economics of it that like
for my time and the ingredients and
renting a kitchen or whatever,
it wasn't inexpensive, you know,
I had to charge a lot of money.
And so that meant that it was already
like naturally narrowing down the group of
people to whom I could teach this stuff.
So I came into work one day and I
was like, I think if I had a TV show,
I think if I had a cooking show
where I taught people how to cook,
I could reach so many more people.
I could do it so much more efficiently
and it would really make a difference.
And being Berkeley, my two friends
were like, that's a terrible idea.
You are a terrible capitalist
who you know, has totally,
totally like sold out because the idea,
they're like in Berkeley,
most people like don't have television,
they don't let their
kids watch television.
So the idea that I could possibly want
to do television was just like so sort of
morally uncouth or whatever.
And so that really sort
of stung me at the time,
but I now I recently
remember it, I was like, oh,
this has been something I've thought
about and wanted for a long time.
So when the opportunity to turn the
book into a show presented itself,
I was like, yes, this is amazing.
I get to do something different.
I think there's a lot of
food TV out there. Um,
they're sort of two types of it.
There's like the really accessible
sort of everyday cooking stuff that is
generally shot in a studio with like
not so great lighting and is meant to be
sort of like getting you to
make some simple stuff at home.
And then there's the really aspirational
like cinematic stuff like chef's table,
which is not so much about cooking as
it is sort of like a hagiography of a
different chef. And it's really
like aspirational and quite elite.
And so I was really upset when I thought
about it that there was nothing that
existed that was beautiful and
cinematic, but also accessible. You know,
why I didn't exist at the
intersection of these two things.
And so I knew that I wanted to
make something gorgeous and, um,
just inspiring and,
but also be for everyone.
And there were ways in which that was
very easy for me to translate because I
had already been distilling those ideas
into the book and into the way I wanted
the book to look and the Vision I had for
the way the book would be in the world
and function in people's lives.
And then there were entirely new things
that I had to learn throughout the
process of, um, because I've
never made a show before.
So one of the things that I like looking
back after having gone through both all
of the pre production and then 40 weeks
of like production and post production,
I mean I kept saying to people, they'd
be like, when will you have time?
I was like, imagine I'm pregnant 40
weeks. Like imagine I'm pregnant,
call me when the baby's born.
Cause like,
that's how and how intense this
thing is going to be. And so, um,
they,
that one of the things that I did not
anticipate but realized pretty quickly
that I was so good at and I
really enjoyed doing was I,
for some weird reason,
I don't know why I have this ability
to ignore the cameras and just be me.
Like I don't change at all. And so
there's a way people kept saying, Oh,
you're a natural,
you're a natural.
And so I think that's what
they were referring to was
that I'm the exact same on
camera as I am off camera.
And I had to learn, you know,
some basic things like where to stand
and what's light and where do I look and
where do I not look? But,
um, that was great. Perfect.
One more for safety.
You're like, yeah, totally.
I mean everything like 50 times.
And I also,
because I'm a perfectionist would take
it really personally at first and I'd be
like, oh no, I did it wrong. I have to do
it again. And pretty quickly I realized,
oh,
we're doing it again.
And it has nothing to do with
me doing it right or wrong.
It's because they need a different
angle or he messed some to the sound guy
messed something, you know,
there are just so many variables.
So the way that like I could
deliver the energy high every time,
but you know,
and that was a,
that was stuff that I
guess isn't something that
everyone has. So I had that.
So that was great. And then can I pause
for one second? All sorts. I think that,
and this is pure speculation, but
you've taught so much, I think that you,
I think that you hone that ability
also in the process of teaching. Uh,
I just, I've seen that overlap,
uh, for, for some folks.
So I don't know how much of it is
nature versus nurture. But yeah,
I definitely think for sure,
and also even just cooking itself,
cooking is a repetition,
right?
Like cooking is everyday you
come in and do the thing again,
whether you did it perfectly yesterday
or really badly yesterday and so,
and there's, you just have to put
your head down and do it again.
And so I feel like there were
certain, like, I don't know,
callouses that I had formed just
from my other jobs that made,
made me be like ready to
be good at this. But, um,
it's funny that
there were so many things I didn't know
because I'd never done it before and
also nobody explained to me. And so
there are, in retrospect, I'm like,
because maybe I'm a teacher who likes
to put people at ease and explain things
to them throughout the process. There
would be these things that I would learn,
like distill an articulate and then
at the next day, the next shoot,
the next time we were with someone else,
I would be able to explain this cause
we were going around the world and
bringing all sorts of different people,
um, onto the screen with us. And so,
and almost none of them had ever
been on camera before. And you know,
we show up with this crew of 25 people
and all these trucks and all this
equipment and lighting. It's so much
stuff and it's so overwhelming for people.
And especially in some of the places
that we went where it was really off the
beaten path, like very rural
places in Japan and in Mexico.
And so I kept trying to do,
it's that beginner's mind
thing where I'm like, okay,
how do I put myself in this person's
shoes and imagine what it feels like to
have this whole like Rodeo show up. You
know, it's like a circus and so, and what,
what, what is that making you
feel like? And when, you know,
when it's not explained to these guys,
oh we're going to have to
do everything 17 times,
but it's not because you did it wrong,
you know?
So the things that I learned along
the way, I would say to everyone like,
don't worry,
like we have to do it a lot of times,
but it has nothing to do with
you. You're perfect, you're fine.
Or just look at me like
don't look at them.
Or there's a lot of sort of talking in
the background that you have to tune out.
And a lot of the time
they're calling your name.
Cause if they're talking to each other
about focusing the camera on you.
So I had to be like, just ignore
if you, if you hear your name,
they're not talking to you,
you know,
cause you're natural human responses
to turn to whoever is talking about,
you know,
saying your name.
So there are these like little things
that I learned that made it easier for me.
And then I,
I took a great pleasure in being the
guide for whoever we were sort of because
it's my job to put that person that cooks,
that grandma I'm cooking with at ease
so that she can be her best self and we
can get the best footage from
her and it's, I don't know,
it's that maternal thing or whatever.
It's that teacher thing. And um,
I realized that I was really good
at that. And so I, I I, yeah.
And it was just nice to
have an entirely new field,
an entirely new skill to hone in terms
of just like, what is it to be on camera,
what is it to like work
with these different people.
That part was really fun.
I really,
really enjoyed it.
Really excited for you. And I'm also
really excited for everybody to see this.
I'm excited. Uh, can you
just, just to look at the,
the overall structure of the,
of the show,
how many episodes are there total?
There's four episodes and each one's
about like 50 ish minutes long.
And um, it, it sort of
matches the structure of the
book. So there's salt, fat,
acid and heat.
And in each episode we go to a different
country to sort of explore the nuances
of that element.
But then through voiceover
and storytelling and a
beautiful archival imagery,
like really our, our team who was digging
up the archival did such a good job. Um,
we're able to connect everything back
to some sort of a universal message of,
you know, like I couldn't, we went
to Japan for salt, but honestly,
we could have gone to any country
for salt. We went to Italy for fat.
We could have gone anywhere for fat.
So it's this way where
like through the specific,
I find a way to then connect it
to the universal. And I do, I, I,
my hope for the show and what I think
from like early small feedbacks that I'm
receiving is that what I wanted it to
do was to give you a few little nuggets
that you could like put in your pocket.
And like same as the book,
never have to return to the book,
never have to return to the show,
never have to like refer to me again.
And that these are going to be the little
things that change the way that you
cook.
And so from what I've heard is that
people are doing it like they're doing the
stuff I told them. Do you know?
And so if, if, um, you know,
I think especially where like
where Netflix is concerned,
there's so much beautiful like
food documentary and food,
this and even like food
competitions on there.
But I think this is the first show that
is really sort of aimed to like get you
cooking.
You know,
I'm so excited. Yeah. I need
a reboot. I've been, I have,
I mean, I do enjoy cooking.
Uh, but this, this I think is,
is such a fun,
culturally rich way to do it.
Uh, so I want, let me ask you,
as people are listening
to this and they're,
and they're getting excited to not only
see these various locations and cultures
and learn from you as you're
pulling them into these stories,
salt, fat, acid, heat.
So I read somewhere,
I think it was on the kitchen.com that uh,
as one of your indulgences
and maybe you've changed,
you can feel free to change
is a local olive oil,
meaning local to you over on
the west coast from cats winery.
And then there are a few other things.
Could you recommend as people who
want to just grab a few tools?
Oh yeah. Uh, you know,
there's no budget limit,
but we're not going to be buying a,
you know, the latest and greatest, uh,
super expensive, you know,
immersion circulator or
something. But like something,
are there a handful of things?
Maybe they overlap like a nice salt,
like some type of fat acid,
big.
Anything that you can think of that most
home cooks may have neglected her or,
or not incorporated that people can
just run out and grab and preparation.
Yes. Okay. Oh, this is exciting.
Okay. For Salt, I think, um,
that Maldon salt,
which is the British salt is the little
pyramid flakes that comes in a little
white box. Yeah. That is now more
readily available in grocery stores,
but also you can buy it on Amazon. And I
feel like that not only tastes amazing,
but it has this incredible
texture that you,
you just putting a little bit on top of
cookies or even ice cream is amazing.
But also any salad, tomato
toast, I don't know.
I have a huge jar of it
that I just reached into all
the time at home. So good.
It's so good.
I think one thing that I learned about
on the show that sort of blew my mind is,
um,
that I really hope will,
will catch on after the show is
how different and how far superior,
uh,
good soy sauce is too regular.
So I saw us like the regular
everyday sorta Kiko man. And um,
and the way you know,
it's a good one is that it's been aged
in a wooden barrel versus a stainless
steel tank.
So often it'll say like wooden,
wooden barrel age or barrel aged
on the thing. There's a brand,
probably the brand that's the easiest
to come by in the states is called Nama
show you. And again, you
can buy that on Amazon.
And so, um, but it's also like,
probably in like higher end stores.
I've also seen it at whole
foods and it's a little bit,
it's like $9 versus two 50, you
know, but it's one of those things,
the flavor is so much richer and so much
deeper and like bounces off all of the
sort of, um, like angles of
your mouth. It's amazing.
It's so incredible. And so I would
say that soy sauce is really special.
Um, olive oil wise.
Yeah, I would say cats.
Olive oil is really delicious.
Um,
and also there's another one that's
local to here to us in California called
Seiko Hills, which is made on
an Indian reservation. It's so,
it's like amazing Scca like dry Eka Eka.
Yeah.
And those two are some two of the like
nicest California olive oils and Seiko
Hills is actually I think
relatively expensive,
inexpensive and you can
buy it in bigger things.
So that's kind of my everyday
olive oil now. Um, um,
and then acid wise, I mean
I a lime, it's my favorite,
but if you're going to buy again
vinegar wise, I think I'm a nice rice.
Vinegar is really delicious.
Like I'm just discovering
how much more delicious,
you know,
I tried in my recipe testing,
I try to cook with the everyday stuff
that you can buy at any grocery store so
that it,
my recipes are pretty accurate to like
what anybody is going to make anywhere in
the country instead of rent,
like very specific niche ingredients.
But sometimes, you know, when
I'm making my own dinner at home,
I just want to have like the delicious
rice vinegar. So that same brand nom nom,
a shot show you,
they make a really delicious rice
vinegar that's just so fantastic.
And there. Yeah, so that's a really good
one. And then he is really, oh here,
this is a luxury. This is a little bit
expensive, but it's the most amazing,
the most amazing,
the most stuff.
So I would say like, you always want to
have a great pan. And so for me, I'm,
I'm generally,
I often say just have a cast iron pan.
It's the most used pen in
my house as a cast iron.
I bought at a flea market
for like 25 bucks. But um,
if you want to graduate up from a
cast iron, there is a company in,
I believe they're in Virginia. It's
called a blank creatives, B, l, a.
N.
C.
They make these beautiful
hand forged pans that are um,
they're steel. There's some sort
of a cast steel. They're like,
have this beautiful bluish tint and they,
this pan is unbelievable.
My best friend gave me one
for a gift a few years ago.
And for whatever reason I didn't start
using it really regularly until recently.
It blows my mind how good it is because
it browns just like a cast iron pan and,
but it heats up.
It's much lighter,
it heats up a lot more quickly and um,
and it just,
it retains its heat.
They're just a delight to use.
These pans are a delight to use. I have
no, I don't know how else to say it. Like,
and it just, everything that
comes out of it is so good.
Do you cook everything or can
you cook, for instance, if,
would you cook eggs in this
or would you have said yes
and your eggs wouldn't stick?
Nothing would like,
because it's definitely has a seasoning
that you have to um, keep up, you know,
and it will rust. It will rest
even a little bit more easily.
Like sometimes if I don't dry mine
really well out in the morning,
they'll be a little rust forming,
so I have to wipe it away.
But it's that seasoning that makes it
so beautiful and perfectly nonstick.
They're also just very gorgeous and look
like a beautiful handmade object and
they're, you know, I think they're in
the $200 range, but like a pen, I dunno,
people buy the liquor is a pots for 300
bucks and they use him for 30 years.
So I feel, I feel okay giving a
one expensive pen recommendation
by seasoning.
Are you say like heating it up,
putting salt in it and
like kind of scratching the
surface or is it really just
letting it absorb the
various oils and so on?
Yeah,
it's just the fact that it like I,
I'm not so good with the science of
metal and then these pans and stuff,
but I think what happens is as you cook
or if you intentionally like rub it with
some fat and then put it in
the oven and let it get warm,
the fats turn into Paul.
It's called I think polymerization.
And so the sort of almost
like fill in the little,
any holes that might be in the metal,
like invisible minute tolls and
then create a really smooth surface.
And so that smooth,
the smoother that surface is,
the more non stick the thing
will be. Which is why, you know,
when you buy a cast iron
that's not yet seasoned,
if you even touch it with your fingers,
you can feel that it's a little
bit pebbly in there, you know,
and that Pebble Enos
is where things stick.
Is it like that Pebble Enos
is stick sticking stuff and
tough lawn exists at the
complete other end of the range where
there's, it's like almost entirely smooth.
So the smoother the thing is,
the less sticking you'll have
here here.
Uh,
well I mean I think that this is,
I think this is an exciting
place to probably tie up.
I encourage everybody to check out
the book and the show. Of course.
Uh,
they can find you on the interwebs and
it's Instagram and Twitter at Chow Samine
or seminar. So I'm now,
now I'm working on,
I'll just say something to keep it easy,
but at Chelsea and C,
I a o Semyon on Instagram,
Twitter on Facebook,
forward slash so mean dot.
No route.
And then a salt fat acid,
heat.com is where they can
find information about, uh,
the TV show as well on
that, uh, at the euro
and all the wonderful people.
I'm like writing profiles
of all the people that we
got to meet so you can learn
more about the people from the
show when the website launches.
Yeah. And I will also link to
everything we've talked about in the,
in the show notes as per usual for folks.
So people listening can go
to tim.blog/podcast for the
links to everything we've
discussed, including the show
at the products, the books,
everything that has come up with a
email to Michael Pollan. That's right.
And if you can find it,
the actual,
the actual wordsmithing that you use
with Michael Paul and I would love to see
that. So I'll put that in the
show notes if we can find it.
Is there anything else that you would
like to say or ask of people listening or
suggest to people listening, uh,
before we, before we wrap up?
Gosh, no, happy cooking.
Use where? Salt. Don't forget the lime,
all your feelings and don't forget
your feelings. Uh, well what,
what a gift to spend time with you.
Thank you so much and so much.
This was so like emotionally resonant
and fun and just really beautiful.
So thank you. Oh my pleasure.
Entirely. Uh, this, this is maybe,
maybe my therapy is doing this podcast.
Maybe that's why we're
here. That's my version of
therapy. Uh, well once again,
really appreciate you taking
the time today. Uh, the, the,
the show looks beautiful.
I really hope people check it out and uh,
to be continued.
I hope we have many more conversations
and to everybody listening as always.
And until next time,
thanks for tuning in.
Hey guys, this is Tim again. Just a
few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by freshbooks.
Freshbooks is become the goto cloud
accounting software for literally millions
of small business owners
who found a faster,
more efficient and much less stressful
way to deal with their numbers and
ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at.
It is used by many of the fastest growing
startups I've invested in or advise
and it's equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis. It is one of the
easiest ways to send invoices,
get paid to track your time and track
your clients if you're self employed and
managing business sometimes means
wrestling with spreadsheets,
crumbled receipts and other scattered
pieces. Freshbooks can really help.
Freshbooks allows you to do many,
many different things very easily.
Preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice. It takes about 30 seconds.
You can set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about
two clicks,
which on average we'll get you paid
twice as fast they're new proposals.
Feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline is part of your
estimate. There are many, many
other things. Tracking your time.
The quick proposals that I mentioned,
formatting free, super easy,
late payment reminders so you don't have
to chase people. Automatic expenses,
sharing files and messages with your
client's award winning customer service.
They are extremely responsive.
The interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve,
so in short it's easy.
It saves you time.
And right now freshbooks is offering
an unrestricted 30 day free trial.
For all of my listeners to claim yours,
check it out.
Go to freshbooks.com forward slash Tim
and enter Tim Ferris in the how did you
hear about us section and that is funky,
spelled t I m.
F. E. R. R. I. S. S. So again,
go to freshbooks.com forward slash
Tim and Inter Tim Ferriss from the,
how did you hear about us section?
Check it out. I get asked all the time.
If you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one
nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to
ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole
food meals throughout the rest of the
day. If you want to give
athletic Greens to try,
they're offering a free 20 count
travel pack for first time users.
I always travel with at
least three or four of these.
This represents a $100 value,
so if you by Athletic Greens,
you get an extra $100 in free product,
so check it up.
Athletic greens.com
forward slash Tim again,
that's athleticgreens.com/tim for your
free travel pack with any purchase.